[Musique]
bonsoir à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver sur Public Sénat pour un
moment important vous allez vivre le
vote finale du Sénat sur la réforme des
retraites les sénateurs devraient voter
ce soir sur l'ensemble de ce texte on le
rappelle et bien hier le gouvernement a
utilisé la procédure du vote bloqué
l'article 44 3 de la Constitution ça
veut dire que les sénateurs n'ont plus
les moyens de modifier cette réforme des
retraites ils vont seulement présenter
leur dernier amendements et ce soir
normalement et bien ils devront se
prononcer sur l'ensemble de ce texte
avec des amendements triés sur le volet
par le gouvernement vous allez pouvoir
vivre cette soirée en direct sur notre
antenne et sur notre site internet
public sénat.fr allez on va retrouver
Mathias arrêt ce qui est ce soir dans la
tribune de l'hémicycle du Sénat Mathias
comment va se dérouler cette soirée bien
ça y est Alexandre on rentre dans là
dernière ligne droite ça y est sauf
retournement de situation le texte
devrait bien être mis au voie ce soir et
ce notamment grâce à une déliquescence
de l'obstruction cordiale menée par la
gauche depuis le début de ce texte alors
soit ne soutenant plus c'est amendements
soit tout simplement en étant absent
voire même par renoncement comme on a pu
le voir plusieurs fois cet après-midi
notamment avec le chef de fil des
socialistes Patrick canard alors une
gauche qui pour autant elle l'assure
elle n'a pas rendu les armes qui vous
avez une victoire dans les heures qui
viennent qui est fort probable une
victoire à la Pyrrhus ou je ne sais pas
à quoi en tout cas sachez que si nous
avons résisté si nous résistons nous
continuerons à résister contre cette
réforme dont les Français ne veulent pas
ils ont encore exprimer tout à l'heure
une réforme qui est marquée par le
mépris le mépris du président de la
République vis-à-vis notamment du monde
syndical finalement ça n'est que la
réplique de son quinquennat précédent
vous n'avez pas respecté les corps
intermédiaires et bien donc malgré votre
fatigue malgré aussi notre fatigue parce
qu'on parle un peu plus que vous vous
l'avez compris nous continuerons à être
présent nous continuerons à être présent
dans cette hémicycle pour dire non à
cette réforme il faut la retirer par
ailleurs les groupes de gauche le
confirmé à notre micro un nouveau combat
devrait s'ouvrir au Conseil
constitutionnel
il y a un certain nombre de mesures dans
cette réforme qui n'ont strictement rien
à voir un projet voilà par exemple
financement de la sécurité sociale donc
il y a plusieurs motifs tout ça
chapeauter effectivement pour des motifs
d'insincérité et de lisibilité de la loi
et je trouve que c'est de notre
responsabilités de législateur que
d'interpeller le Conseil constitutionnel
sur surtout cela et nous ne sommes pas
le seul à le dire puisque plusieurs
grands constitutionnalistes constatent
la même chose que nous et de la vie du
texte ici dans l'hémicycle on se dirige
vers la fin de l'examen des amendements
il en reste à peu près une centaine puis
nous passerons aux explications de vote
Alexandre pendant environ une heure 7
minutes pour chaque groupe avant le vote
solennelle merci beaucoup Mathias aller
direction l'hémicycle du Palais du
Luxembourg pour la dernière ligne droite
de ce débat sur la réforme des retraites
au Sénat sur les bas revenus la mise à
contribution sociale des accessions de
rémunération des accessoires de
rémunération que sont la participation
l'intéressement l'augmentation de la CSG
sur le capital l'augmentation de la
contribution sociale de solidarité etc
etc la liste serait bien entendu plus
longue mais pour ce convaincre des
possibilités de financer autrement il
suffit de se rappeler le titre au titre
d'un grand quotidien du soir dans son
édition d'hier qui ne pourrait nous
donner quelques inspirations sur la mise
en contribution des revenus par exemple
du CAC 40 merci de votre attention merci
Madame le verrou
merci
présidente cet article 19 maintient le
plafond des dépenses du fond de
solidarité vieillesse pour l'année 2023
se font finances la dépense liée à la
prise en charge de prestations comme les
allocations du minimum vieillesse aux
personnes
âgées pour tous les régimes de retraite
qui en assurent le service selon
l'adresse en 2019
75% des allocataires du minimum
vieillesse vivent plus souvent sales 54%
des allocataires sont des femmes l'âge
moyen des allocataires est de 74 ans le
fond de solidarité vieillesse finance
aussi la dépense liées à la prise en
charge sur des bases forfaitaires de
cotisations de retraite au titre de la
validation des périodes non travaillées
en cas de chômage le recul de l'âge de
62 à 64 ans creusera davantage les
inégalités et allongera le sas de
précarité entre emploi et retraite
l'économiste Michael Zemmour qui nous a
beaucoup éclairé pour comprendre les
effets de votre réforme je le salue
il nous explique que pour les ouvriers
et plus encore les ouvrières
l'allongement du sas de précarité entre
emploi et retraite elle est fait le plus
important de la réforme en 2019 à 61 ans
le taux d'emploi des ouvriers des
ouvrières et de seulement 28 % tandis
que le taux des ouvriers et des ouvriers
ni en emploi ni en retraite est de
35%. selon l'INSEE en 2017 la réforme de
2017 traduite par une hausse de 14
points du taux d'emploi à 60 ans de 13
points du taux de chômage et de 7 points
pour l'invalidité et la maladie par
conséquent le projet de loi risque
d'augmenter pour le FSV le fond de
solidarité vieillesse la dépense liées à
la prise en charge sur des bases
forfaitaires de cotisations retraite au
titre de la validation des périodes non
travaillées en cas de chômage ou une
activité globalement votre réforme est
injuste et injustifié elle doit être
retirée je vous remercie nous allons
prendre monsieur Ferro
merci
madame Ferret
défendu merci Monsieur gilet merci
Madame vanègue
merci
Monsieur chanterelle
Madame le héros
[Musique]
monsieur Durand
monsieur Cardon
quand même
merci madame la Présidente moi je vais
faire court donc c'est ah oui quand même
article 19 donc c'est effectivement une
suppression de cet article donc cet
amendement des sénateur socialiste
écologiste et républicain visa rejeter
la confirmation des prévisions des
charges des organismes concourants au
financement des régimes obligatoires
FSV tel que le gouvernement la prévue
dans cet article merci
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues au-delà des projections de PIB
de masse salariale d'inflation
très faible par rapport à ce que nous
disent certains économistes reconnues
certains qui avancent même qu'on va
rentrer dans une période de stagnation
de de
composer d'inflation et de décroissance
par rapport à long terme et également
qui diminue à euroconstant c'est à dire
corriger de l'inflation le paragraphe 2
de cet article 19 indique et je le cite
mot pour mot la trajectoire financière
traduit la normalisation progressive de
la situation sanitaire
a très bien je pose la question au
ministre c'est quoi la normalisation
sanitaire en matière de sanitaire et des
systèmes de santé est-ce que vous êtes
allé le dire et l'expliquer sur le
terrain au personnel des hôpitaux des
EHPAD des services à l'accompagnement à
domicile des services de infirmiers à
domicile des personnels des secteurs
psychiatriques qui sont en grande
difficulté et qui vivent leur situation
professionnelle comme un abandon de
l'État voilà allez-y allez leur parler
sur le terrain vos projections ne sont
pas à la hauteur des besoins de
financement d'un projet national de
santé
reconsidérés et conforter c'est la
raison pour laquelle avec cet amendement
1300 nous demandons la suppression de
l'article 19 madame meunier
madame Poumirol
madame meunier
monsieur caner
monsieur Assouline
monsieur joli
merci Madame président de Monsieur
ministre mes chers collègues il s'agit
d'un amendement visant à supprimer cet
article je voudrais simplement noter que
cet article prévoit une diminution du du
fond de solidarité vieillesse alors même
que les besoins sont importants et sont
devant nous et alors même que pour
permettre à nos personnes âgées de vivre
dignement il serait souhaitable de
revaloriser cette cette allocation de
solidarité c'est une raison
supplémentaire pour
considérer que cette loi est une
mauvaise loi sur cet aspect en
particulier et même si elle concerne
principalement la réforme des des
retraites et une réforme qui vous le
savez n'est pas du tout accepté par nos
concitoyens à travers les manifestations
qui a eu au cours de ces derniers jours
mais surtout parce que 90% des actifs
sont opposés à cette allongement de
l'âge du de cette prolongation de la
juré à la retraite et donc c'est une
réponse aux problématiques du de la
vieillesse d'une manière générale qui
est ne prend pas en compte les attentes
de nos concitoyens et au surplus il
s'agit d'une sorte de mépris à la fois
de nos concitoyens qui ne sont pas
entendus mais également de notre
assemblée puisque les différentes
mesures ont renforcé ce qu'on appelle le
parlementarisme rationalisé mais qui est
ici aujourd'hui dans le cadre de cette
réforme un parlementarisme bâillonné
merci
monsieur Tissot
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
bon normalement propose la suppression
de cet article 19 qui fixe la prévision
de charge de fond de solidarité
vieillesse se font à punition de
financer divers avantages vieillesse à
caractère non contributif qui relève de
la solidarité nationale la prévision
affichée à cet article 19 ne nous semble
pas à la hauteur des besoins aussi faut
de pouvoir l'abonder puisque seul le
gouvernement a le droit de créer des
dépenses dans nos textes budgétaires
nous voulions ouvrir des barres avec cet
amendement suppression au moment où nous
avons déposé nos amendements nous
savions pas encore avec quel mépris le
gouvernement les traiter l'opposition
sénatoriale et que de débats il n'y en
aurait pas un maire demandait partement
consterné par l'absence de réponse de la
majorité sénatoriale et du gouvernement
dès le début de nos débats m'a suggéré
de rester silencieux pendant les deux
minutes de mon temps de parole cela
aurait pu être tenté ne serait-ce que
pour voir si nos collègues de droite
s'en sera aperçu tant ils se sont voulus
se faire sourire à nos propositions et à
nos arguments depuis la semaine dernière
mais avec mes collègues de gauche j'ai
préféré continuer à me faire le
porte-parole de nos concitoyens ceux-ci
sont nombreux à nous écrire chaque jour
depuis deux semaines pour vous demander
de vous faire entendre la réalité de ce
qu'ils vivent pour essayer de vous faire
comprendre que le sacrifice que vous
leur demandez c'est deux ans de leur vie
n'est pas possible à consentir et bien
qu'il soit des millions de Français à
s'exprimer par tous les moyens à leur
disposition quand cette réforme les
sondages d'opinion les réseaux sociaux
les interpellations de leurs élus et
bien sûr c'est si grands manifestations
il ne se heurte qu'à votre mépris ce
même répris ou pas dans ce même mépris
avec lequel le président de la
République traite les syndicats qui
présentent pourtant un front unique
historique ce mépris ne fera
qu'alimenter la colère de nos
concitoyens et conforter leur
détermination amener la bataille
jusqu'au bout contre ces réformes et
pour paraphraser la chanson entendez le
cri sourd du pays qu'on alien religiem
retirez votre projet
merci le 40 64 de Madame assassin
monsieur Baptiste
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre puisque vous avez de toute
façon acté que nous amendements ne
méritaient pas d'être mise au vote je
vais profiter de ma prise de parole pour
dénoncer un aspect brutal et inutile de
votre effort en effet sur bien des
points notamment en poursuivant la casse
des régimes pionniers attachés à des
professions pénibles vous attaquez
notamment aux industries électriques et
glacières telles que DF à la Régie
autonome des transports parisiens
l'éclair et employé de notaire la Banque
de France les membres du CESU vous avez
préféré protéger les intérêts des plus
privilégiés
plutôt que de vous attaquer justement à
leurs intérêts en dégradant les régimes
dit spéciaux ce que vous faites avec la
suppression de ces régimes pionniers et
tout simplement insupportable et injuste
d'où notre amendement de suppression je
vous remercie
merci Madame Vogel pour le 32 12 merci
madame la Présidente tout d'abord je
voulais dire que je voulais remercier
mon collègue Guy benaroche qui a pris la
parole qui vous a passé un message de ma
part ce matin je ne pouvais pas être là
car j'étais à Bruxelles retenu par la
réunion de la direction du Parti vert
européen dont je suis la coprésidente et
je sais pas pourquoi ça vous énerve et
ça m'a donné l'occasion de parler à mes
collègues européens de ce qui se passe
évidemment en France et je voulais vous
dire le quoi qu'on pense des différents
systèmes au niveau européen et quel que
soit la position que les uns et les
autres et sur l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite en France en Espagne en
Allemagne au Danemark wire chacun et
chacune est scandalisé par l'étendue de
la violation du débat démocratique en
France
c'est un fait manifestation historique
90% des actifs opposés à la retraite à
64 ans et votre seule réponse c'est le
mépris envers l'opposition sénatoriale
le mépris du président de la République
envers les syndicats le mépris envers
les salariés et les Français nous allons
nous retrouver à voter dans cette
chambre après un débat insincert des
abus de procédure sans que l'Assemblée
nationale ne se soit prononcé sans que
le Président de la République accepte de
parler avec certains cervicales avec des
millions de personnes descendues dans la
rue alors que je suis prête à parier que
personne dans cette chambre très
certainement ne va être directement
touché par cette réforme
avant de conclure j'aimerais vous
demander malgré tout et même si vous ne
partez vous ne partagez pas toujours
toutes nos idées sur tous les bancs
d'aplombir en son absence notre collègue
Raymonde pensait mange pour la
conviction l'esprit et les tripes
qu'elle a mis dans cette bataille je
vous remercie
et d'applaudir aussi ses équipes en
général et les nôtres qui pendant des
jours et des nuits ont été mobilisés
pour ceux à quoi elle croit profondément
je vous remercie merci
quelle est la vie de la commission
madame la rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres chers collègues la Commission
en fait se félicite du retour à
l'équilibre rapide de du FSV qui sera à
2,8 milliards d'euros d'ici 2026 et je
pense qu'on doit se poser la question
d'une réaffectation en fait d'une part
de la CSG soit au régime au régime
général soit à la CADES donc c'est une
réflexion que je pose et en tout cas en
tout état de cause la Commission est
bien avis défavorable à l'ensemble de
ses amendements de suppression monsieur
le ministre
merci madame la présidente madame le
rapporteur a dit l'essentiel je partage
et son avis et son sentiment sur les
réflexions à avoir par ailleurs il
s'agit d'un article obligatoire dans le
cadre de la présentation d'un pays FSS
qui interdit d'une certaine manière tout
suppression s'offrent le texte
absolument impossible à adopter
merci nous passons un article 20
les demandes de parole madame ponce
madame Lubin
merci madame la Présidente moi je
voulais juste au travers de cet article
rappelé que au final
avec les
comment dire les petites douceurs que le
gouvernement aura accepté à la demande
de la majorité du Sénat pour adoucir ce
projet de loi pour le faire apparaître
un tout petit peu moins brutal
ça arrange bien le gouvernement d'un
côté ça arrange bien aussi la majorité
sénatoriale bien au final nous ne savons
plus ce que va coûter ou rapporter bien
que le terme ne me plaise pas du tout
cette réforme elle était faite au départ
pour économiser 18 milliards d'euros
je serais bien curieuse de savoir et
nous serons bien curieux de savoir d'ici
deux ans ou trois lorsque les chiffres
sortiront ce que ça aura clairement
amené moi je vous le dis je pense que
cette réforme sera une réforme pour rien
au niveau des finances publiques
n'écoutera très cher à tous les salariés
qui seront concernés
le coup je vous remercie madame
varaillas
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues je voudrais pour ma part
revenir sur le passage certes un peu au
lieu du président de la République
récemment au salon de l'agriculture il a
pris l'exemple des agriculteurs pour
illustrer sa pensée sa vision du travail
et au fond le sens de sa réforme des
retraites je cite le président quand
vous parlez à un éleveur qui ne sait pas
ce que c'est qu'un jour férié qui ne
sait pas ce que c'est qu'un samedi ou un
dimanche où il peut se reposer il trouve
sa juste il aurait pu prendre le
président de la République l'exemple des
mineurs de charbon du XIXe siècle pour
justifier les régressions de sa réforme
en matière de pénibilité ou encore le
travail des enfants au siècle dernier
pour présenter l'allongement de la durée
de cotisation oui les agriculteurs
français ont du mérite et si leur
situation vous préoccupait vraiment vous
n'auriez pas attendu une proposition de
loi des communistes pour revaloriser
leur tension et cet égard je veux rendre
un hommage particulier à mon collègue
André Chassaigne à l'Assemblée nationale
pour le travail le travail remarquable
pour le travail remarquable qu'il assume
et sur le sujet au fond quel est le sens
des mots du président il y a des
contraintes il y a la profession qui
sont indéniables mais si les
agriculteurs travaillent autant
s'entraide et si longtemps c'est d'abord
parce qu'ils sont mal trop mal rémunérés
ils sont mal rémunérés pour la même
raison que vous faites cette réforme des
retraites parce que vous avez choisi
votre camp celui des grands groupes
celui des profits et c'est valable
autant pour les pétroliers que pour les
géants de l'agroalimentaire alors si
vous respectez réellement le travail des
agriculteurs indispensable pour notre
autonomie alimentaire ce n'est pas en
vous attaquant au régime de retraite de
nos concitoyens que vous résoudrez le
problème mais bien agissant pour le
rassurer une rémunération juste et digne
à la hauteur de leurs efforts
merci Monsieur Lemoine et voilà vous
suivez ce soir la dernière ligne droite
de ce débat au Sénat sur la réforme des
retraites pour en parler on va retrouver
Mathias arez dans la tribune de
l'hémicycle du Sénat Mathias quand on
entend les prises de parole dessinateurs
de gauche et bien on comprend que ça
sent la fin de ses débats absolument
Alexandre le compteur des amendements
qui restent à défendre et tant chute
libre il y a une ambiance morose on a
repris il y a un peu plus de 20 minutes
ici dans l'hémicycle on est passé de 101
amendements à 49 et 49 et 49 ne seront
pas défendus puisque vous l'entendez
depuis tout à l'heure à chaque fois que
la présidente Rossignol appelle un
sénateur pour défendre son amendement et
bien on entend beaucoup de défendu
défendus défendu c'est une ambiance
morose ici et donc des débats qui se
finissent un petit peu plus rapidement
que prévu avant la prochaine étape
Alexandre vous le savez les explications
de vote qui devraient durer un petit peu
plus d'une heure avant le vote
solennelle au moment où je vous parle il
reste donc 48 amendements à défendre
merci beaucoup Mathias aller en retourne
dans l'hémicycle par leur présence par
leur assiduité par le travail en
commission et bien ont voulu apporter
leur pierre à l'édifice de ce sauvetage
du système des retraites parce que c'est
grâce à eux aussi dans quelques minutes
je l'espère dans quelques heures après
peut-être d'ultime
d'ultime
procédure qui peut être seront utilisés
et bien nous permettrons de regarder nos
enfants et nos petits-enfants en face
parce que nous savons que nous aurons
agi pour les prochaines années et que
c'était indispensable alors c'est vrai
qu'il est plus facile parfois de tenir
le beau rôle mais nous tenons le rôle
qui est le nôtre avec fierté et avoir
que la conviction d'avoir fait le
travail qui était nécessaire je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
nous allons maintenant présenter les
amendements je commence par le 308
monsieur Ferro
le 394 madame Ferret
le 546 monsieur Gillet
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre article 18 article 19
article 20 faut-il le rappeler pour cet
article qui rajoute 400 millions d'euros
mais essentiellement lié à la
réalisation du minimum contributive à la
revalorisation accordée pour attraper
l'inflation
cet article en fait illustre aussi tout
le système complexe que l'on essaye de
mettre en place en termes de filet de
sécurité de politique de solidarité et
donc dans le cadre de ce pdf le fait
d'essayer de mettre les enveloppes
nécessaires à l'ensemble de ces demandes
mais ça illustre aussi le fait que dans
une nouvelle démocratie dans ce 21ème
siècle il serait grand temps aujourd'hui
de réfléchir vraiment en profondeur sur
le revenu de base le revenu universel
qui devrait assurer un socle financier
un socle de solidarité tout au long de
la vie que l'on soit jeune moins jeune
ou qu'on soit gé ou retraités ce socle
de bac de base permettrait vér
tremblement de simplifier nos
dispositifs de simplifier le système qui
est particulièrement complexe et il
rentrerait bien dans un régime
aujourd'hui de revenus globaux pour
l'ensemble des populations dans laquelle
dans lequel bien sûr la retraite devrait
pleinement s'intégrer donc vous voyez
bien que il s'agit bien de mettre en
prospective véritablement des réformes
de fond et cette réforme là je vous le
redis elle reste toujours calé à la fin
du 20e siècle ce n'est absolument pas
une réforme d'anticipation ce n'est
absolument pas une réforme de prise en
compte des évolutions sociologiques ce
n'est absolument pas une réforme de
prise en compte des besoins nouveaux et
voilà et cet article 20 même modestement
dans cette prise de parole l'illustre
totalement je vous remercie
[Musique]
madame
la collègue avec cet article 20 dont
nous demandons la suppression se termine
l'examen de votre projet de loi
réformant la retraite projet inutile et
injuste pour les travailleurs de notre
pays les conditions par votre faute dans
lesquelles nous avons traité ce texte
qui va impacter de manière néfaste nos
concitoyens est inédite dans notre
assemblée réputé sage et attaché au
travail de fond et au débat d'idées
de votre faute monsieur le ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs nos collègues de
la droite sénatoriale de votre faute et
en particulier par l'activation de la
procédure de votre bloquée nous avons dû
renoncer à débattre sur nos propositions
nombreuses et alternatives notre travail
parlementaire a été foulée au pied les
élus de la République que nous sommes
méprisés les Français ont compris votre
manœuvre il ne le comprennent pas ils ne
la comprennent pas ils ne le
pardonneront pas vous porterez la seule
responsabilité du vote de ce texte
néfaste pour eux sauf si en conscience
et sur le fil vous décidez à retirer
votre projet vous le pouvez encore je
vous remercie la parole et maintenant
monsieur chanterelle
merci madame la Présidente donc nous
sommes au dernier article de cette de
cette réforme pendant 10 jours nous
avons bataillé jour et nuit contre cette
réforme des retraites injustes et
brutales article après arthrite nous
avons démonté les mentions du
gouvernement sur la nécessité de cette
réforme sur le déficit du système de
retraite sur la revalorisation des
petites pensions sur le coût des régimes
spéciaux face aux centaines de
propositions que nous avons faites pour
des financements alternatifs pour une
meilleure prise en compte des carrières
hachées pour une revalorisation des
pensions des femmes pour une meilleure
prise en compte de la pénible des
pénibilités au travail pour améliorer le
temps d'emploi des seigneurs nous avons
trouvé un mur la droite sénatoriale
s'est enfermée dans le silence en
refusant de participer au débat et les
gouvernements dans la surdité en
refusant d'écouter nos arguments main
dans la main ils se sont obstinés à
bâillonner l'opposition
usant de tous les stratagèmes possibles
pour couper cours au débat les articles
38 et 42 du Règlement du Sénat qui
limite le nombre d'arateurs pour voir
s'exprimer la réécriture d'articles
faisant tomber plus de 1000 amendements
puis l’article 44.2 de la Constitution
qui autorise le gouvernement a s'opposer
à l'examen de dizaines d'années et enfin
l'arme de destruction massive du débat
le 44-3 ou votre bloqué qui met fin à
tout débat contradictoire et oblige à un
vote unique sur le texte et les
amendements choisis par le gouvernement
face à la résistance de l'opposition le
gouvernement a du procéder à un coup de
force pour faire passer une réforme dont
personne ne veut mis à part la droite
sénatoriale brutalisant le Sénat pour
obtenir un vote de force le gouvernement
à brutalisé le pays dans la rue et au
Parlement nous continuerons de nous
battre pour préserver les acquis sociaux
des Françaises et des Français et pour
faire échec à cette réforme illégitime
merci Madame le héros
cet article 20 ajoute 400 millions
d'euros au plafond des dépenses de
l'assurance vieillesse pour l'année 2023
si c'est 400 millions supplémentaires
sont liés notamment à la revalorisation
du minimum contributif et à la
revalorisation accordée pour attraper
l'inflation cet article entérine
l'ensemble de la réforme du gouvernement
cet article tient compte des premiers
gains attendus du report de l'âge de la
retraite à la
de l'âge de la retraite de 62 à 64 ans
vous oubliez les multiples budgétaires
négatifs de cette réforme selon le FCE
si on cumule la dépense induite chômage
maladie et les effets macroéconomiques
contraction des salaires baisse de
l'activité l'économie réalisée tombe à
2,8 milliards d'euros à horizon 10 ans
le Haut Conseil des finances publiques
établit qu'elle devrait coûter 600
millions d'euros il n'est pas en mesure
d'évaluer l'incidence de moyens internes
de la réforme des retraites sur les
finances publiques or l'incidence la
majorité des Français et des Françaises
la ressentiront dans leur corps meurtri
64 ans par conséquent la trajectoire
établit dans cet article 20 est infondé
en cohérence avec ce que nous avons
défendu tout au long de l'examen de ce
projet de réforme des retraites
c'est-à-dire notre opposition totale et
argumentée à cette réforme injuste et
injustifiée nous demandons la
suppression de cet article 20 nous
dénonçons ainsi le mépris envers
l'opposition sénatoriale nous dénonçons
le mépris du président de la République
envers les syndicats qu'il refuse de
recevoir nous dénonçons le mépris envers
les salariés nous dénonçons le mépris
envers les Français une seule issue
raisonnable le retrait
je vous remercie madame Patrice compta
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
examinons ici le dernier article de ce
texte si 400 millions d'euros
supplémentaires sont liés notamment à la
revalorisation du minimum contributif on
ne peut oublier en ce moment les
approximations voir les contre-vérités
proférées par le gouvernement depuis
deux semaines sur ce minimum retraite à
1200 euros avant d'être confondu au
terme de l'examen de ce texte quel bilan
tristesse et colère car le choix d'un
plfsr nous a empêché de prendre en
compte de nombreuses situations en
raison des règles d'irrecevabilité d'un
texte budgétaire ça c'était l'acte 1
puis nous avons eu l'acte 2 les articles
38 42 du règlement intérieur du Sénat
petit livre vert devenu célèbre enfin
l'acte 3 c'est l'artillerie lourde
l'article 44 de la Constitution le vote
bloqué qui permet au gouvernement de
choisir les AM avons débattus le
gouvernement voulait une victoire il ne
l'a pas eu à l'Assemblée nationale
d'autant qu'une partie de sa majorité
relative ne veut pas de ce texte il a eu
au Sénat il a piloté le texte main dans
la main avec la droite sénatoriale quand
tous les moyens constitutionnels tous
les moyens de nos règlements sont mis en
oeuvre pour faire passer un texte dont
les Français ne veulent pas quand les
syndicats ne sont pas reçus par le
Président de la République après un
mouvement social inédit il y a un
problème démocratique que vous devrez
assumer devant les Français
osez vous après ça une CMP conclusive
droit dans les bottes rien ne nous
permet d'en douter quant à nous nous
battrons jusqu'au bout contre cette
réforme
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
madame de La Gontrie
merci monsieur Durand
monsieur Cardon
merci Madame le présidente juste
puisqu'on est au dernier article et que
nos collègues Galler sont pressés de
faire voter cette loi
c'est pas de la provocation c'est c'est
factuel c'est des faits
bon en tout cas on va voir si vous avez
bien révisé alors combien y a eu de
manifestations historiques 6 ça commence
à rentrer désactive opposé à la retraite
à 64 ans 90 %. voilà et votre sœur est
réponse c'est le mépris bon ça c'est ça
vous savez mépris envers les positions
et surtout le mépris du président de la
République envers les syndicats qui
refusent de recevoir mes prix envers les
salariés et les salariés et les
Françaises et les Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime et donc il reste
effectivement quelques heures quelques
normalement au moins un jour et quelques
heures vous avez on a bien compris que
le compteur était sous surveillance
sur le l'hémicycle à droite en tout cas
sachez une chose c'est que Monsieur Miss
vous avez encore quelques heures pour
retirer cette réforme
madame Lubin défendu
monsieur moto j'ai
madame condamouret
mais
madame Monier
merci madame la Présidente donc cet
article final augmente de 400 millions
le plafond de minimum vieillesse qui je
le rappelle s'élève à
273,7 milliards il est enterré ne
surtout une réforme injuste et brutale
sur laquelle nous allons bientôt devoir
nous prononcer dans des conditions
délétères n'oubliez pas mes chers
collègues que les Françaises et les
Français nous regardent alors nous
parlons des dizaines et des dizaines de
courriels s'accumulent sur nos boîtes
mails Sénat envoyées par des
enseignantes et des enseignants de nos
départements respectifs qui nous
demandent de les entendre la plupart ce
sont des femmes il et elle s'appelle
Christelle Anne Julie catiana Abdennour
Sébastien Carole Florence Cindy Luke
Bruno Nathalie Delphine comme tant
d'autres il est elle ont consacré leur
vie à l'éducation de nos enfants à faire
vivre l'école publique et laïque de la
République avec courage et conviction
malgré un contexte chaque année plus
difficile lorsque leur mission ça sera
achevée nous leur devons le droit au
repos dans de bonnes conditions voilà ce
dont il est question aujourd'hui être
juste simplement juste avec celles et
ceux qui ont travaillé toute leur vie en
faisant de leur mieux c'est cela
reconnaître la valeur du travail et pas
celle du capital c'est cela la justice
sociale pilier de la République seul
garante de l'adhésion des Françaises et
Français assez principes car si la
République est injuste et brutale avec
celles et ceux qui travaillent durs
alors elle n'est plus fidèle à elle-même
voilà le choix qui est le nôtre ce soir
préserver ce que nous avons de plus
sacré ou prendre le risque de fissurer
une fois de trop le pacte républicain
soyons à la hauteur de cet instant
retirer cette réforme
merci Madame pomirol
madame meunier
monsieur caner
le ministre
alors nous en sommes c'est-à-dire à la
fin de nos travaux bientôt je voudrais
vous livrer ces quelques mots qui ont
été prononcés ici même il y a bientôt
très années
qui s'adressait au rang de la droite
diverses ici présente
vous pouvez bomber le torse mais il y
aura un autre appel cette fois devant le
peuple et c'est lui qui tranchera vous
marquez de mauvais points tous les
sondages le monde les deux tiers des
Français sont opposés à votre réforme
vous devez en tenir compte le
gouvernement se réfugie dans une
position de faiblesse qui sera jugée par
le peuple au-delà des péripéties de vote
de notre assemblée on sait la réputation
du Sénat sous la Troisième République la
Quatrième République et le début de la
cinquième le Sénat ne doit pas redevenir
la chambre noire de la République la
retraite c'est une mesure de
civilisation
ce sont ce ne sont pas les salariés
seuls qui doivent payer il faut mettre
le capital à contribution si vous ne
prenez pas les mesures que le peuple
attend les conséquences seront
redoutables il faut suivre un autre
chemin le nôtre
Pierre Mauroy face à la réforme de 2010
mes chers collègues ces mots sont
prémonitoires
retenez-les retenez les et pour ce qui
nous concerne nous continuerons toujours
en permanence à vous demander monsieur
le ministre de retirer votre réforme
je me suis Assouline
[Applaudissements]
monsieur Joly
monsieur Tissot
je le défends
c'est le dernier madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le présente le présentement et le
dernier de ce texte disait à supprimer
cet article 20 qui accède la
rectification des dépenses de la branche
vieillesse pour l'année 2023 les
objectifs de dépenses de branchevs sont
fixés à 273,7 milliards d'euros pour
l'ensemble des régimes obligatoires de
sécurité sociale contre
273,3 milliards d'euros dans la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 c'est 400 millions d'euros
supplémentaires sont principalement liés
à la revalorisation du minimum
contributif et à l'augmentation accordée
pour rattraper l'inflation lors des
débats nous avons présenté de nombreuses
propositions pour permettre de
réellement revaloriser les pensions de
retraite pour l'ensemble des Français
pour que nos retraités puissent vivre
dignement vous avez fait le choix de ne
jamais entendre nos propositions
pourtant chiffrer et concrète c'est pour
cela que nous proposons la suppression
de cet article que nous jugeons inadapté
et voilà mes chers collègues dans
quelques amendements
nous y sommes à la nous sommes à la fin
de cette réforme de régression sociale
je tenais à saluer l'attitude de
l'ensemble des groupes de gauche qui ont
su dignement représenter les 70% des
Français opposés à cette réforme et des
millions de personnes qui se mobilisent
dans la rue pour dénoncer les
conséquences de cette réforme ensemble
nous aurons pu assister au premier loge
à la confirmation de l'alliance entre la
droite et la majorité présidentielle
d'Emmanuel Macron qui ne seront
particulièrement qui se seront
particulièrement bien entendu pour
utiliser l'ensemble des points du
règlement pour contrevenir au droit
parlementaires la fin de l'examen de ce
texte n'aura malheureusement pas été à
la hauteur des attentes des Français
mais nous continuerons inlassablement à
défendre la justice sociale pour nos
concitoyens
le 31 9
9 merci madame la Présidente et quoi
après
des millions de personnes manifestent on
n'a jamais raison sans le peuple et
encore moins contre lui
donc ce texte va être adopté par notre
chambre il a été rejeté à l'Assemblée
nationale nous avons débattu ou plutôt
soliloqués pendant toute la première
partie
vous avez voté notamment l'article 7 et
puis la belle machine feutrée du Sénat
c'est déréglé tous les articles de
réduction de la capacité d'intervenir
des oppositions ont été mises en œuvre
nous allons voter ce soir et demain
demain une CMP cette sénateur cette
députée vont adopter un texte qui sera
rejeté par 70 à 80% des Français selon
les âges qu'on considère et après chers
collègues et après si la démocratie se
fait sans le peuple qu'est-ce qu'il y
aura après et nous serons tous concernés
par ce qui viendra après
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame Cohen oui merci madame la
Présidente cet article 20 prévoit les
dépenses j'apprends branche assurance
vieillesse censée justifier la réforme
des retraites discuter depuis 10 jours
ici au Sénat cet article permet de
constater que l'allongement de la durée
de cotisation à 43 ans et là je l'égal
de départ en retraite à 64 ans aura pour
conséquence d'ici 2026 de réduire le
déficit de soi-disant de 15,7 milliards
à 14,9 milliards d'euros ainsi donc non
seulement votre réforme est injuste pour
les Françaises et les Français qui vont
devoir travailler deux années
supplémentaires impopulaire puisque 80%
d'entre elles et eux sont opposés à
cette réforme mais également
inefficace puisque le déficit du système
des retraites demeure c'est pourquoi
nous demandions un amendement de
suppression pour notre part nous
proposons une réforme pour un droit à la
retraite à 60 ans avec une pension à
taux plein garantie pour une carrière
complète avec prise en charge de
cotisations pour les périodes de travail
y compris les périodes le chômage de
formation des études du congé parental
maladie invalidité un projet alternatif
plus juste qui tient compte de la
pénibilité des carrières longues c'est
possible ce serait possible si on
faisait le choix d'augmenter la
cotisation des employeurs en mettant à
contribution les revenus financiers des
entreprises en donnant aux salariés de
nouveaux pouvoirs d'intervention dans
les entreprises en augmentant les
salaires en garantissant l'égalité
salariale entre les femmes et les hommes
conformément à la loi le gouvernement et
la majorité sénatoriale nous disent fin
des 35 heures 43 années 64 ans nous
répondrons que pour nous c'est 32 heures
37 et à nuit et demie et 60 ans donc
retraite de cette retraite de cette
réforme illégitime qui est injuste et
inutile écoutez la voix des Françaises
et des Français écouter les voix
majoritaires qui s'élèvent dans le pays
stop au mépris le président de la
République doit recevoir les syndicats
et vous devez abandonner ce projet
néfaste
merci quelle est la vie de la Commission
[Applaudissements]
oui merci Madame
la présidente merci madame la Présidente
effectivement on arrive au moment de
l'équilibre de la branche vias c'est cet
article 20 et on voit que le solde par
rapport à pellfest
2023 était dégradé de 300 millions
d'euros et je dirais presque tant mieux
tant mieux c'est la traduction des
dépenses supplémentaires liées
faire en sorte que des mesures sociales
soient prises à travers de l'effort
supplémentaire qui est demandé aux
français et notamment effectivement
c'est une dégradation du solde liée
notamment à la revalorisation des
petites pensions à travers le minimum
contributif le myco mais également à
travers la revalorisation revalorisation
de la PMR le minimum pour les les
agriculteurs donc on voit bien que quand
on prend des dispositions qui font en
sorte qu'on va vers un rééquilibre de
notre système de retraite avec derrière
des recettes supplémentaires il faut
faire en sorte de prendre un certain
nombre de mesures sociales elles ont une
répercussion immédiate quand la
répercussion de l'augmentation des
recettes est plutôt plus tardive et
c'est la raison pour laquelle plus en
retard d'apprendre des décisions
monsieur le ministre et plus la réforme
est difficile c'est a fait quatre ans
que l'on propose ce type de réforme
justement sans prendre de retard pour
faire en sorte que on arrive à
l'accompagner de façon beaucoup plus
facile néanmoins pour 2009 23 le solde
sera encore de
-3,9 milliards en ce qui concerne la
branche vieillesse et on voit bien que
ce sol continue à se dégrader au fil des
temps surtout si on le prend aucune
mesure compensatoire et il se dégrade je
vous le rappelle mes chers collègues
avec une diminution une diminution de
pouvoir d'achat de nos retraités puisque
le niveau moyen des retraites en
diminuant dans les trajectoires que l'on
a déjà étudié notamment à travers le
corps
en ce qui concerne cet équilibre nous
avons effectivement proposé un choix
difficile
aux Français un choix qui effectivement
demande un effort collectif c'est la
raison pour laquelle les mesures
sociales d'accompagnement
pour le plus grand nombre pour le plus
grand nombre parce que la réforme
Touraine c'est pour ceux qui commencent
tôt le décalage de bornes c'est pour
ceux qui commencent à donc la réforme du
mélange des deux est une réforme plus
équitable la réforme des gens anticipée
c'est permettez madame c'est pour
prendre en compte effectivement les
usures professionnelles et donc les
accompagnements que nous avons proposé
dans la commission notamment à travers
la recette la retraite progressive ou à
travers la capacité permanente pris des
60 ans sont des mesures qui adoucissent
effectivement l'usure supplémentaire qui
peut être traduite dans des métiers
difficiles contenus de l'effort
supplémentaire que nous réclamons mais
que faire quand vous avez un système par
répartition il y a pas 36 solutions on
l'a déjà on l'a déjà largement défini
quand vous avez un nombre de cotisants
qui baisse une durée de retraite qui
dure de plus en plus longtemps les
Français comprennent bien qu'il faut
quand même faire quelque chose et c'est
simple si on ne propose pas
si on le propose pas effectivement cet
effort collectif au générations
d'aujourd'hui ce sont les générations
suivantes qui le paieront et si vous ne
faites pas ça le système est simple et
vous le savez bien vous le savez bien ça
veut dire quoi une augmentation des
cotisations sur une baisse du pouvoir
d'achat pour ceux qui travaillent une
baisse des retraites c'est une baisse
une baisse des pensions une baisse des
pensions c'est une baisse du pension
c'est une baisse du pouvoir d'achat pour
les retraités est-ce que vous pouvez
laisser leur rapporteur poursuivre s'il
vous plaît et en conséquence
depuis plus de 4 ans nous l'avons dit
nous ne souhaitons pas faire des
retraités pauvres c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous assumons nos
responsabilités pour faire en sorte que
l'on propose un système qui certes est
un effort on le reconnaît bien
volontiers mais qui est tout à fait
nécessaire pour faire en sorte que l'on
puisse équilibrer ce système et donner
confiance à nos jeunes mais l'affaire
n'est pas fini
l'affaire n'est pas fini monsieur le
ministre
puisque j'espère un vote bien sûr
positif de notre assemblée et nous
allons attaquer la phase suivante de la
CMP sachez monsieur le ministre que nous
avons travaillé largement ce texte pour
proposer je vais y arriver pour proposer
des mesures pour proposer des mesures
d'adoucissement et ça mais madame
assassy c'est à moi en tant que
rapporteur membre non madame rapporteur
je suis membre de la majorité
sénatoriale ça n'a échappé à personne
mais en tant que rapporteur je serai
membre de la CMP en tant que rapporteur
membre de la CMP je me permets n'en
déplaisse à certains de m'adresser à
monsieur le ministre pour lui dire que
nous serons ferme sur les propositions
que nous avons proposé par rapport ce
sont des propositions de justice sociale
qui sont indispensables pour la pour
l'adoption de ce texte je tenais à vous
le dire devant vous toutes et vous tous
car c'est une affaire d'importance merci
monsieur le ministre quel est votre
quel est votre avis sur ses amendements
la vie est défavorable toujours comme
depuis lundi 14 parce qu'il s'agit de
d'articles sont obligatoires si on veut
que le pdfss soit recevable il y a un
certain nombre de règles organiques qui
déterminent les articles obligatoires et
le contenu obligatoire d'un PLFSS qu'il
soit rectificatif ou initial et donc la
vie par définition défavorable je
voudrais simplement ajouter deux
remarques la première c'est que la
dégradation du solde que qui apparaît
dans cet article et le signe tangible
illustration tangible des effets des
premiers effets en 2023 de la mise en
oeuvre de la réforme que nous vous
proposons d'adopter c'est parmi les
premiers signes tangibles et les plus
importants de l'impact des conséquences
que le texte que nous vous proposons
d'adopter peut avoir à et j'espère on
aura bien sûr sur les comptes sociaux de
l'année 2023 et c'est donc un des
éléments qui
nous permet et qui nous a autorisé à
faire le choix d'inscrire les mesures
que nous portons dans le cadre d'un
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale rectificatif puisque
nous trouvons là la trace très directe
comme dans les autres tableau d'ailleurs
des mesures que nous vous proposons
d'adopter la deuxième remarque que je
voulais faire tiens au débat qui s'est
ouvert à l'occasion de la présentation
des amendements de suppression et si
j'ai bien entendu la réponse de Monsieur
rapporteur sur la question de
l'équilibre financier le gouvernement
est c'est la dernière intervention que
je ferai très certainement sur les
tableaux financiers et l'on saisit donc
l'occasion le gouvernement souhaite à la
fois mener une réforme qui permet
d'améliorer le système de retraite nous
pouvons avoir des divergences mais ce
que j'ai noté des différents débats
c'est qu'en matière de pension minimum
de pénibilité d'aménagement des
carrières longues d'emploi des seigneurs
d'attributions de droits que beaucoup
ont qualifié de mesures justes je pense
à sapeur-pompiers je pense aux orphelins
je pense aux possibilités de rachat
trimestre
la difficulté qui peut apparaître ou la
divergence qui peut apparaître entre
nous n'est pas une divergence
d'opportunités mais une divergence de
curseur sur la possibilité d'en faire
trop de d'en faire pas assez sur ces
points là il y a un autre aspect sur
lequel il y a une divergence très claire
c'est comment est-ce que nous assurons
l'équilibre du système nous avons fait
un double choix le premier choix c'est
l'équilibre c'est le retour à
l'équilibre en 2030 parce que nous
considérons que le meilleur service à
rendre en génération qui viennent et
finalement le principal acte de
solidarité c'est de garantir l'équilibre
du système et j'ai en tête les mots que
j'ai prononcé dans la discussion
générale sur le texte
toutes les responsabilités que j'ai eu
l'honneur d'exercer toutes les
expériences que j'ai vécues et chacune
des fonctions que j'ai eu à remplir mon
convaincu que l'équilibre financier la
discipline budgétaire sont les
conditions de l'action et sans les
conditions de l'action et des priorités
politiques que nous pouvons avoir et
donc ce premier choix c'est l'équilibre
et le deuxième c'est d'atteindre cet
équilibre sans remettre en cause la
politique de compétitivité que nous
menons depuis maintenant de nombreuses
années qui je crois en termes d'emploi
d'attractivité et de redressement
industriel pensez fruits et sans toucher
au pouvoir d'achat des Français qu'ils
soient cotisants ou bénéficiaire des
retraites c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons fait le choix du travail et
c'est comme cela que nous avons
construit l'équilibre budgétaire de ce
système et c'est aussi une des raisons
qui m'amène à confirmer la vie
défavorable du gouvernement sur cette
série d'amendements
je vous remercie nous allons donc
maintenant passer au dernier amendement
de du projet de loi et le dernier
amendement étant normalement
vous inquiétez pas vous inquiétez pas
encore des choses à dire elle va dire
mais effectivement effectivement c'est
pas c'est pas hasard que le dernier
amendement qui va même au-delà du texte
au-delà du dernier article soit écrit
par ma collègue Raymond Poncet Mons qui
avait envie qui avait vraiment envie de
débattre de steak je t'avais déposer
légèrement sur tous les articles et que
vous avez frustré vous avez frustré son
envie de débattre notre envie de
débattre
d'abord en choisissant ce véhicule
législatif avec un temps contraint on va
le redire c'est en contraint qui était
déjà un premier signe de votre fébrilité
par rapport à votre à votre réforme qui
au cours au cours des discussions vous
avez peu à peu est un débat d'abord
puisque la droite sénatoriale a fui le
débat sur l'article 7 à fuil des bas sur
le report de 62 à 64 ans la mesure la
plus brutale le cœur de cette réforme
vous avez déserté le débat vous avez par
une manœuvre parlementaire fait tomber
les amendements de la gauche et vous
nous avez contraint à ne pas en parler
et puis vous avez au fur et à mesure
encore plus contre un débat quand on
avait commencé à démontrer
l'inefficacité la faiblesse des mesures
d'atténuation de la brutalité de la
réforme cette fois-ci c'est le ministre
qui a dégainé le 49-3 sénatorial pour ne
pas que nous puissions en débattre alors
vous allez sûrement vous satisfaire d'un
vote du Sénat ici dans quelques heures
peut-être
mais vous aurez créé des fractures
profondes des fractures profondes dans
ce pays avec les travailleurs mobilisés
avec les manifestations qui ont été
massives auxquelles vous êtes vous êtes
restés sourds avec l'ensemble des
syndicats au mépris au mépris des
millions de travailleurs puisque on va
le redire 9 travailleurs sur 10 sont
hostiles à cette réforme et vous les
avez
ignorez vous avez brûlé tous vos navires
monsieur le ministre votre seul bruit de
sauvetage était ici la droite
sénatoriale une des droites les plus
conservatrices du pays qui vous a
accordé son vote ici au Sénat mais votre
réforme est-elle non nécessaire injuste
et brutal nous continuerons de le dire
et travailleurs continueront de le dire
le pays continuera le vous le dire
jusqu'au retrait je vous remercie
la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président puisque ça
n'a pas été fait je vais me permettre de
présenter l'amendement
et vous
il y a une inversion des rôles
donc
préciser que la présente loi ne
s'applique pas dans les dans les
collectivités d'outre-mer
merci
voilà
la Commission n'a pas retenu
effectivement ce type de raisonnement
car nous pensons que loi de la
République doit s'appliquer dans tous
les territoires
on doit certes considérer les
différences qui peut y avoir notamment
avec nos amis des outre-mer et nous ne
les avons pas oublié à travers ce
dispositif puisqu'on a pris un certain
nombre de mesures concernant Mayotte
concernant des revalorisations et
concernant également
la différence qui existait déjà dans le
recours sur succession en ce qui
concerne l'espace grâce à Viviane Mallet
cela fera partie encore de discussions
monsieur le ministre je tenais à le
souligner nous n'oublions pas nos
outre-mer néanmoins avis défavorable par
rapport à votre proposition
défavorable avis du gouvernement
avis défavorable
mais attends mes chers collègues
nous allons procéder au vote unique sur
le texte
en application de l'article 44 dernier
alinéa de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 alinéa neuf du Règlement du
Sénat
le gouvernement a demandé au Sénat de se
prononcer par un seul vote
sur les articles 9 à 20 on ne retenant à
partir du moment où cette demande a été
formulée que les amendements proposés ou
acceptés par le gouvernement
sans remise en cause des amendements
précédemment adoptés à l'article 9
mais aussi sur l'ensemble du texte
monsieur le ministre contre tenu des
retraits d'amendements intervenus et
pour la clarté la sincérité de l'audiba
et de notre vote pouvez-vous nous
rappeler la liste des amendements et
sous amendements acceptés par le
gouvernement je vous donne la parole
merci monsieur le Président voici donc
la liste des amendements et des
sousaments et des sous-amendements
acceptés par le gouvernement dans le
cadre du vote unique demander en
application de l'article 44 derniers
alinéa de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 à Linéa neuf du Règlement
du Sénat pardon pour le caractère un peu
fastidieux mais pour l'article 9 les
amendements 21 33 21 34 21 36 47 61 21
35 21 37 20 30 39 21 43 21 44 21 46 21
47 21 48 21 50 et 21 52 pour l'article
10 les amendements 21 54 20 59 rectifiés
tiers rectifié terre pardon 21 55 20 58
rectifié 20 60 rectifier bis 21 56 21 57
21 58 21 59 21 60 et 46 50
pour les amendements portant
additionnels après l'article 10 les
amendements numéro 22 95 20 24 21 61
rectifié bis 45 47 46 475 rectifiés pour
l'article 11 les amendements 24-88
rectifié bis et 2162 pour les
additionnels après l'article 11
l'amendement 1904 rectifier bis un
article 12 l'amendement 2163 21 64 et 21
65 pour l'article 13 les amendements 216
21 67 21 69 21 70 21 71 21 72 21 73 214
21 75 21 76 21 77 23 60 rectifié bis 21
78 21 79 21 80 21 81 21 82 et 47 57 et
vous suivez en direct sur Public Sénat
le vote final sur la réforme des
retraites qui est débattue depuis 10
jours à la Haute Assemblée alors on le
rappelle derrière le gouvernement a
déclenché un article un peu spécifique
de la Constitution l'article 44 alinéa 3
pour et bien organiser la procédure dite
du vote bloqué ça veut dire que les
sénateurs depuis hier non plus les
moyens de modifier le texte de la
réforme des retraites il pouvait
justement présenter leurs amendements et
bien au final et c'est à dire maintenant
il va y avoir un vote unique sur ce
texte de la réforme des retraites un
texte avec les amendements qui ont été
adoptés et bien jusqu'à vendredi par le
Sénat et puis avec certains amendements
qui ont été sélectionnés par le
gouvernement et qui sont en train d'être
listés par le ministre du Travail
Olivier du soft au moment où on se parle
on entend au niveau du stop d'ailleurs
qui a terminé à cette liste
d'amendements et donc le vote unique du
Sénat sur la réforme des retraites va
pouvoir être procédé de l'article 42
aliés à singe de notre règlement et
conformément la décision de la
Conférence des Présidents lors de sa
réunion du mercredi 8 mars je vous
rappelle que les explications de vote
sur l'ensemble de ce projet sont limités
à un orateur par groupe politique pour
une durée de 7 minutes chacun et un
sénateur ne figurant sur la liste donc
un groupe pour une durée de 3 minutes je
vais maintenant donner la parole pour
explication de vote tout d'abord pour le
groupe les républicains au président
Bruno Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues
enfin nous y voilà
c'est la fin de ce marathon nous voilà
parvenus au terme de cette course
législative à cet instant que nous
croyons il y a quelques jours encore
inaccessibles nous voilà parvenus à cet
acte le vote qui fonde la légitimité du
Parlement notre raison d'être et je le
pense aussi notre honneur et pourtant
chers collègues de gauche vous avez tout
fait pour empêcher cet acte fondamental
par l'obstruction par l'obstruction plus
de 8000 amendements et de sous
amendement des rappels au règlement en
veux-tu en voilà vous avez été recherché
dans notre règlement toutes les
techniques qui permettaient d'empêcher
d'empêcher le vote vous étiez mauvais
perdant puisque vous aviez par avance
anticipé votre défaite et c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous vouliez
empêcher le vote mais nous y voilà et ce
vote sera pour nous déjà une victoire
mes chers collègues mes chers collègues
cette obstruction
vous a permis d'entendre énormément de
prises de parole de nos collègues de
gauche sans que on sache bien qu'elle
s'était vos propositions vos solutions
le Yaka faucon oui le yakafocon oui
souvent mais que faites-vous pour faire
face
à ce grand choc que la France va devoir
dans les prochaines années affronter
l'autre choc il y a bien sûr le choc
climatique mais il y a aussi le choc
démographique du vieillissement les
départs en retraite vont être multipliés
par 4 par 5 que faisons-nous que
voulez-vous faire nous nous agissons
nous avons voulu agir et cette réforme
nous l'avons voulu monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre mais Monsieur le
Ministre du socle tout particulièrement
je voudrais m'adresser à vous
vous irez porter ce message au président
de la République c'est très fort nous
allons la voter mais nous ne souhaitons
pas pour lui c'est très forte nous la
votons parce que c'est notre réforme
c'est ici qu'elle est née nous la
voterons parce que nous l'avons modifié
ces notes que nous allons voter la
surcotte pour les maires de famille
les orphelins handicapés la lutte contre
la fraude
l'emploi des seniors qui sont souvent
trop souvent à l'âge de 57 ou de 58 ans
au chômage les questions de la
pénibilité de l'usure professionnelle ce
sont ces ajouts que nous avons voulu
apporter à ce texte là si nous votons
cette réforme ce n'est pas parce que le
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron la
propose dans c'est pour l'intérêt
national
parce que nous voulons sauvegarder un
régime de retraite par répartition j'ai
entendu les moqueries sur les questions
de chiffres et d'équilibre non ceux qui
se moquent des chiffres se moquent des
français derrière les chiffres il y a
des déficits derrière il est difficile
il y a l'argent des Français et derrière
l'argent des Français il y a la peine
des Français
le régime pas répartition que nous
soutenons c'est celui qu'il faut sauver
parce que demain sinon il y aura un
effondrement du pouvoir d'achat de nos
aînés et nos jeunes devront payer deux
fois la retraite notre votre retraite
est leur propre retraite c'est cela que
nous voulons évidemment préserver comme
nous voulons préserver la croissance de
demain qui est le chemin de la
prospérité et derrière cette réforme il
y a le taux d'emploi il y a cette
capacité que nous aurons de mettre
encore plus de travail dans l'économie
française nous sommes le dernier un des
derniers pays européens par la quantité
de travail et c'est la pauvrissement
assurée si nous en restons là nous
voulons ce chemin de croissance ce
chemin de prospérité vous voulez la
décroissance le déclassement et la
pauvrissement mais au-delà de ces
considérations matérielles
nous nous battons pour quelque chose de
beaucoup plus essentiel que les
retraites ou la croissance nous nous
battons aussi pour des conditions
immatérielles nous nous battons parce
que derrière cette réforme derrière ce
régime intergesse générationnel il y a
un lien il y a ce lien entre les
générations qu'expriment le régime par
répartition et c'est ce lien qui nous
manque tant en France dans une France
archipelisée morcelée fracturé qui
matérialise que nous sommes un peuple
une seule communauté nationale voilà
pourquoi nous allons monsieur le
ministre mesdames Messieurs mes chers
collègues la voté et je terminerai par
des remerciements remerciements d'abord
aux rapporteur au rapporteur à la
rapporteur général qui a fait preuve
d'une grande combativité
[Applaudissements]
remerciements à notre rapporteur à notre
rapporteur René Paul Sabari avec son
énorme travail
avec sa
zénitude bravo chers collègues à notre
président de commission
notre président de commission dont la
voix au perché se transforme parfois en
lames coupantes et certains le savent
ici et on en fait les frais merci à tous
les trois je voudrais aussi remercier
nos collègues qui ont été présents
regardez cette présence encore merci mes
chers collègues d'avoir enduré des
séances qui n'a portait souvent rien
aucune solution
mais où il fallait refaire face au
manœuvres d'obstruction des oppositions
merci mes chers collègues monsieur le
Président enfin je voudrais terminer une
fois n'est pas coutume parce que je ne
pense pas que dans l'histoire récente du
Sénat notre administration nos services
ait été autant mises à l'épreuve je ne
parle pas de la quantité d'arbres qui
ont dû être rabattu pour être transformé
en sous amendement
je parle du travail
je parle du travail de l'administration
du Sénat qui est aussi notre honneur qui
a montré dans des moments extrêmement
tendus difficiles qui a toujours tenu
qui a joué son rôle de conseil parce que
pour nous c'est fondamental je veux
parler bien sûr du secrétaire général de
la séance mais aussi de tous les
collaborateurs et je vous propose
précisément mes collègues pour terminer
ce marathon de vous lever et de les
applaudir
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas tous les jours comme ça
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Monique
Lubin va s'exprimer pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
messieurs les ministres madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame et monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues je vais
moi aussi commencer par remercier tous
ceux qui ont travaillé sur ce texte
effectivement très important de cette
mandature
nos collègues
rapporteurs bien évidemment madame la
Présidente de la Commission
l'administration dans son entier tout ce
que l'on voit tout ce que l'on ne voit
pas et bien évidemment tous nos
collaborateurs soyez remercier de ce
travail extraordinaire de ce travail de
fond pour ce qui fut en effet un
marathon
cette journée monsieur les ministres et
Mesdames Messieurs restera une journée
noire pour tous les salariés de ce pays
nous savons que vous voterez le recul de
l'âge de la retraite de 62 à 64 ans
parce que nous savons chers collègues
que vous avez négocié avec le
gouvernement
pour voir aboutir ce que vous attendez
depuis si longtemps
parce que nous savons messieurs les
ministres que le gouvernement s'est
soumis
afin de s'assurer le vote majoritaire du
Sénat dont vous avez impérativement
besoin pour apporter un minimum de
légitimité à votre texte
j'irai droit au but
vous avez voulu faire peur aux Français
en leur disant que les régimes de
retraite étaient en faillite et c'est
faux si c'est faux
votre réforme est une réforme
idéologique
vous n'avez jamais été favorable aux
mesures qui permettent tout salarié de
ce pays de vivre mieux
vous n'avez pas aimé la retraite à 60
ans vous n'aimez pas les 35 heures
vous n'aimez pas tout ce qui dans ce
pays peut servir à asservir un peu moins
tous les salariés votre votre
réforme est injuste elle était injuste
parce qu'elle concerne essentiellement
les salariés les plus proches de leur
départ à la retraite ceux qui
travaillent depuis longtemps ce qui
exerce les métiers les plus difficiles
ce qui perçoivent la plupart du temps
les salaires les plus modestes elle est
brutale parce qu'elle prend effet
immédiatement dès septembre 2023 aucune
réforme depuis celle de 1982 ne s'est
appliqué immédiatement autrement dit à
des salariés dont le départ à la
retraite est prêt ou en cours de
préparation aucune réforme des retraites
n'a jamais été aussi brutal dans ce pays
elle est brutale pour les salariés qui
ont commencé à travailler entre 18 et 20
ans parce qu'il y aura bien un report à
l'âge de 62 ans malgré tous les éléments
de langage que vous avez déployés pour
affirmer cette donne
elle est inéquitable parce que les seuls
efforts vont porter sur les salariés
rien n'est demandé aux employeurs au
prétexte que nous serions déjà trop
exigeants avec les entreprises de ce
pays en termes de cotisations sociales
et d'impôts pourtant depuis cinq ans les
cadeaux fiscaux et sociaux pleuvent sur
les entreprises à un niveau jamais connu
en France
elle est brutale
dans sa totalité et pour vendre votre
projet de loi
vous avez essayé
de nous compter des histoires
et je mesure mes mots vous savez essayer
de nous de nous vendre
que les femmes y trouveraient leur
compte que les femmes seraient les
grandes gagnantes de cette réforme il
n'en est rien et cela a été démontré
immédiatement c'est tellement faux que
la majorité vous arrache un bonus pour
compenser la perte de bénéfice des
droits familiaux qui s'imposera aux
femmes mères de famille qui devront
travailler deux ans de plus
vous avez aussi essayé c'est presque
encore plus grave c'est au moins aussi
grave de nous faire croire que tous les
salariés qui ont eu de retraite complète
auraient un minimum de retraite à 1200
euros brut ça n'est pas le cas ça a été
démontré nous avons eu même droit à des
excès de langage de certains ministres
qui annonçaient deux millions de
bénéficiaires là où on se rend compte
aujourd'hui que ça sera bien moins que
ça elle est brutale avec les seniors
dont tout le monde sait qu'il rencontre
les plus grandes difficultés à retrouver
un emploi ils verront leur situation se
précariser d'autant plus que vous avez
imposé il y a peu une diminution des
droits au chômage
et puis chers collègues je ne vais pas
passer sur la manière dont vous avez que
vous avez eu d'aborder ce texte vous
avez été quasiment mutique durant toute
la durée de son examen nous avons fait
des dizaines et des dizaines de
propositions aucune n'a mérité que vous
vous y intéressiez vous avez refusé le
débat et en le refusant vous avez manqué
de respect à tous ceux qui vont subir
les conséquences de ce report et qui
voulait entendre vos arguments
vous avez certes apporter quelques
nuances pour faire croire que vous
vouliez adoucir un peu la brutalité de
ce texte mais la vérité c'est que vous
vouliez le durcir encore plus en
proposant un amendement monsieur le
Président Retailleau qui revenait sur la
clause du grand père instauré par ce
projet de loi c'est à dire supprimer les
régimes spéciaux avec effet immédiat
vous n'êtes pas allé au bout parce que
vous risquez d'être mis en minorité et
ça aurait sacrément de permis votre
éventuel victoire
et que dire en fin de l'attitude du
président de la République
qui refuse obstinément de recevoir les
organisations syndicales après des
semaines de protestation
le peuple gronde et le président de la
République regarde d'ailleurs
cela me fait penser à ce qu'avait dit un
autre président de la République
celui
celui qui nous avait donné la retraite à
60 ans celui qui avait amené des
changements extraordinaires dans les
années 80 pour tous les salariés de ce
pays celui qui nous avait prévenu que
vous toucheriez au retraite que vous
toucheriez à la protection sociale que
vous vendriez tout au privé nous aurions
dû l'écouter mais cette phrase reste
désormais marquée en nous le président
de la République actuelle n'écoute pas
le peuple le peuple s'en souviendra
mais je suis
vous suivez en direct sur Public Sénat
les explications de vote sur le vote
unique de la réforme des retraites à la
Haute Assemblée vous venez d'entendre
Monique le bain à la cicatrice
socialiste chef de fil du groupe PS sur
cette réforme des retraites
et maintenant vous allez écouter et bien
le chef de fil la dessinateur centré sur
cette réforme des retraites Olivier
[Musique]
hainauts
madame mesdames Messieurs le rapporteurs
ça y est on y est alors on va tuer le
suspense majoritairement très
majoritairement notre groupe votre race
ce texte on y est un peu fatigué d'avoir
travaillé un peu fatigué aussi de vous
avoir écouté mes chers collègues
mais on aborde de cette fin de
discussion sans regret sans remords avec
une sérénité un soulagement un
soulagement pour la place et la
crédibilité du Sénat un soulagement pour
notre cible voilà nous sommes au bout du
texte comme nous l'avait dit le
président vous n'avez pas été pris par
surprise c'était un engagement qui avait
exprimé le Sénat et son président et il
a été capitaine dans la tempête le Sénat
et son président et la majorité
sénatoriale ont tenu leur objectif je
veux remercier à mon tour les présidents
de groupe pour l'organisation des débats
les rapporteurs un formidable
en argumentation ayant travaillé faisant
notre fierté des batteurs infatigables
ça lui aussi les groupes d'opposition
ils ont fait le choix de la flibusterie
oh disons-le c'était une flibusterie de
notable ça va pas forcément vous faire
plaisir mais c'est ainsi mes chers
collègues
alors ce texte
ce texte
il mérite pas l'indignation que vous lui
avez prêté il mérite pas non plus un
enthousiasme excessif ça n'est pas la
mère des réformes mais il a une utilité
une exigence morale pour les jeunes
générations une utilité parce que
c'était nécessaire alors je vais vous
lire un texte
il n'y a pas d'alternative de nouveaux
efforts notamment des départs à la
retraite plus tardif devront être
réalisés afin de pérenniser notre
système de retraite
je vais répéter on a beaucoup écouté ce
matin en sont là rien lâcher rien lâcher
rien lâcher on revendique à notre tour
le droit à la répétition
et la répétition c'est l'art de la
pédagogie alors il n'y a pas
d'alternative de nouveaux efforts
notamment des départs à la retraite plus
tardif devront être réalisés afin de
pérenniser notre système de retraite
quelle est cette hauteur un affreux
réactionnaire un conservateur un
rétrograde c'est un nom qui sonne à vos
oreilles c'est Pierre Moscovici mes
chers collègues un terme et donc
parfois sur cette dans cette hémicycle
mais je crois que là tout à l'heure on a
touché le fond pardonnez-moi l'amour des
chiffres
ne peut pas faire bon ménage avec
l'amour des gens alors là excusez-moi
j'ai entendu ça tout à l'heure voilà la
responsabilité c'est qu'elle sait
l'amour des chiffres et c'est l'amour
des gens et je pense que vous avez cité
Pierre Mauroy si Jacques Delore avait
entendu que l'amour des chips était
incompatible avec l'amour des gens je
pense qu'il aurait réagi dans cette
assemblée c'est un soulagement pour
notre système de retraite un soulagement
pour les retraités parce que évidemment
il y a ceux qui manifestent mais il y a
aussi
minorité majorité je sais pas
silencieuse les retraités qui après le
vote de ce texte sont sécurisés par
rapport à leur retraite et par rapport
leur risque qui pouvait y avoir sur la
baisse des retraites les jeunes qui vont
pas devoir payer deux fois une double
peine payer leur retraite mais aussi
payer la dette parce que qu'est-ce qu'il
y a de plus irresponsable que de payer
les dettes à crédit nous ne faisons pas
ce choix du paiement des dettes à crédit
c'est irresponsable
ce texte ça a été dit il y a des
avancées les seniors le seniors bien sûr
que le travail plus longtemps pour les
seniors c'est la clé ça a été dit par
Elisabeth par un épaule la question des
familles des carrières longues la
politique familiale la question de
l'égalité homme-femme les tucs faudra
pas en ayant pas voté steak revendiquer
des avantages ou une justice pour
l'étude les pompiers mes chers collègues
et puis les élus grâce à Sylvie
vermeiller les mers et les élus pourront
et c'est pas voir les choses par le
petit bout de la lornguette excusez-moi
pourront racheter des trimestres pour
les élus qui gagnent moins de 1830 euros
par mois mais ce texte n'est pas un
chèque en blanc il y a beaucoup de
choses qu'il faudra aborder la question
de la justice bien sûr cette réforme des
retraites ne peut pas tout la question
du sens du travail on n'est pas acharné
on croit à la valeur travail mais bien
évidemment il faut la qualité de de vie
au travail il faut l'information tout au
long de la vie il faut travailler sur
l'autonomie il faut une grande loi
travail nous sommes partisans de cette
grande loi travail et puis il faut un
dialogue social
et ça nous y tenons beaucoup un
paritarisme rénové refondé et c'est la
raison pour laquelle avec Hervé
Marseille nous demandons l'ouverture le
plus vite possible d'une conférence
sociale et puis soulager par et pour la
démocratie représentative les
que ces articles on n'y serait pas
arrivé vous savez Aristote disait la
politique c'est la rhétorique mais c'est
aussi l'action et la délibération et
donc l'obstruction parlementaire c'est
une impasse ah encore un affreux
réactionnaire c'est Laurent Berger qui
dit ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur votre banc on a cité tout à l'heure
Alfred Jarry les vorace et les curias et
bien oui mes chers collègues les voraces
ont battu les coriaces comme dans Alfred
Jarry mais c'est la gauche radicale qui
a écrasé la social démocratie dans vos
rangs voilà la réalité de ce débat et
c'est
en sac on a aucune gauche rassemblée sur
le plus petit dénominateur commun celui
de la radicalité alors pour conclure je
voudrais citer Charles de Gaulle la
politique la plus coûteuse mes chers
collègues la plus ruineuse pour le
peuple c'est d'être petit et bien cette
citation je vous l'envoie en cadeau le
Sénat sort renforcé les institutions
sont solides la démocratie
représentative est plus crédible et nous
sommes fiers les uns et les autres
d'appartenir à cette majorité
sénatoriale je vous remercie
voilà pour cette prise de parole
d'Olivier Hainaut le sénateur centriste
dans l'explication de votre finale du
Sénat sur la réforme des retraites
sur l'ensemble de ce texte
François Patriat le président du groupe
RDPI le groupe de la majorité
présidentielle aussi rapporteur madame
la Présidente
le choix que nous allons opérer ce soir
est un choix de responsabilité et un
choix d'efficacité
inutile d'être
vindicatif agressif ou caricaturale il
va de l'avenir des générations futures
il y va de l'équilibre de nos systèmes
sociaux demain
je voudrais dire ici que notre assemblée
sur le président a redonné de la
noblesse au débat au débat démocratique
sans noblesse à la fois de débattre le
temps qu'il a fallu 3 nous écouter le
temps de devoir nous aussi la noblesse
de décider parce qu'une assemblée qui
débarque sans voter au bout photo
immunise ou photo détruit par rapport à
son rôle initial quand comment s'est
déroulé ce débat mes chers collègues
s'est déroulé en demi-temps ce sportif
comme vous première mi-temps du 2 au 7
pendant cette première mi-temps chacun a
pu s'exprimer longuement je vous
rappelle que ce débat a donné lieu à
presque 5000 amendements à 10 jours de
débats du sans précédent sur le débat
sur les retraites des 3 débats sur les
traits qui ont eu lieu jusqu'à présent
se dérouler dans un climat plutôt serein
ou l'opposition souhaitait montrer son
soutien à la rue au débat syndical par
ailleurs et arriver à ce débat première
mi-temps qui s'est déroulée avec une
multitude d'amendements
non je me souviens sur l'article
liminaire 52 prises de parole les unes
les mêmes que les autres pour pouvoir se
faire supprimer cet article luminaire je
m'en souviens je me inutile et puis à
partir du 7 la deuxième mi-temps les
masques sont tombés les matchs sont
tombés parce que les marques sont tombés
parce que la volonté de l'opposition
n'était pas tant de débattre ce qu'elle
a affirmé voulu pendant des jours et des
jours mais la volonté de l'opposition
était de faire en sorte que nous ne
puissions pas voter et vous l'avez dit
clairement vous l'avez dit clairement
dans cet assemblée dans les couloirs et
dans les réunions des présidents vous
l'avez dit ne pas voter pourquoi pour
tenter de légitimer un texte
voté par le Parlement or à qui
appartient la légitimité dans ce pays la
légitimité l'appartient au Parlement
elle appartient pas à la rue veut dire
que vous voulez c'est le Parlement qui
décide aujourd'hui et vous savez
d'affronter la rue c'est pas toujours
facile c'est pas toujours facile de
voter des textes populaires c'est pas
toujours facile d'appeler à l'effort
c'est pas toujours facile d'appeler à la
raison il y a des gens ici qui ont pris
le responsabilité qui l'ont fait alors
le choix de la responsabilité de la
sécurité et de l'efficacité nous l'avons
fait il y a t-il eu un bayonnement chers
collègues chers collègues nous avons
écouté et vous nous reprochez parfois
d'avoir été muet mais vous répétiez sans
arrêt les mêmes choses pour occuper le
temps et à chaque fois le rapporteur les
rapporteurs vous ont répondu
techniquement à fond au débat sur ces
sujets le gouvernement vous a apporté à
chaque fois par le ministre les réponses
qu'il avait à apporter il l'a fait il
n'y a pas eu de ballonnements y a-t-il
eu du mépris
à quel moment qui a maîtrise et qui
est-ce que par le fait que sur un texte
de loi annoncé aux Français travailler
depuis des mois décidez demain en quoi
les pénétrer le président de la
République ne méprise pas les syndicats
il les a il les a reçu et les a reçu au
printemps il a fait en sorte qu'ils
entrent au CNR la CGT a refusé de
participer à la rencontre à l'Élysée ne
dites pas que les mépris elle a refusé
mes chers collègues elle a refusé d'y
aller il voulait aujourd'hui il n'y a il
n'y a pas eu de brutalité
un texte qui est débattu depuis quatre
ans ici et on doit s'assembler avec des
rencontres avec tous les syndicats un
débats qui a été mené au fond par le
ministre ici présent par madame la
Première ministre avec les syndicats
pour aboutir à des avancées notoires que
les syndicats ont reconnu en privé mais
n'ont jamais voulu
accepter en public par ailleurs jamais
et toi tu fais donc il n'y a pas eu de
brutalité il y a eu un texte et moi je
le rappelle ici quitte à vous faire
crier ou vous faire maintenant il est
Pender je trouve que ce texte il est à
la fois nécessaire et protecteur et
d'ailleurs les Français ne s'y trompent
pas quand ils disent aujourd'hui à 8
pour 10 qu'il pense que le texte sera
voté ça n'est pas par notre entêtement
parce qu'ils savent très bien en
eux-mêmes que ce texte il est nécessaire
pour assurer la survie la survie du
service pour demain et ils le savent ils
le savent très bien il y a pas eu de
brutalité parce que le parce que les
discussions ont eu lieu il n'y a pas eu
de brutalité parce que le madame la
Première ministre a reçu combien de fois
les syndicats en quoi est-ce que le
gouvernement aujourd'hui n'est-il pas
autorisé ou fait pour faire ce débat
alors voilà ce texte est jeudi il est
d'abord nécessaire je crois que vous
avez utilisé les rapports du corps
qu'est-ce que dit le corps le corps dit
que dans la situation la plus favorable
il y aura 13 milliards de déficit en
2030 et qu'il faut les combler
aujourd'hui vous dites que ce texte est
injuste ce qui est juste demain ce n'est
pas de travailler plus aujourd'hui
injuste ce qui est injuste c'est de
laisser à nos enfants un système en
perdition des retraites au rabais et une
dette supérieure pour la France voilà ce
qui est injuste aujourd'hui voilà ce qui
est induit alors je vous dis moi le
chers collègues je vous le dis
franchement maintenant nous allons voter
ce texte parce que nous pensons qu'il
était non seulement nécessaire mais
qu'il est efficace aussi et ce que je
vous le dis le ministre vous la redit
l'autre jour ce texte une fois voté vous
pensez qu'il va laisser de la rancœur de
la fracture qui paiera aux élections
maintenant je vote un texte ici je ne
sais pas si ça va m'arranger
électoralement ou pas électoralement ce
que je sais est-ce qu'il est bon pour
des pays où est-ce qu'il est nécessaire
et je le sais comme tel et demain je
vous l'assure je suis le ministre
monsieur ministre vous l'a dit aucun
gouvernement ne reviendra sur ce texte
comme ça été fait par le passé vous
pouvez dire aujourd'hui ce que vous
voulez vous-même si un jour vous accédez
au responsabilités que je ne souhaite
pas vous ne reviendrez pas dessus et
vous aurez à redire les propos que vous
avez tenu aujourd'hui alors voilà mes
chers collègues ce prénom je vais
conclure je voudrais à mon tour
remercier ici remercier la Commission et
les rapporteurs qui ont répondu avec
beaucoup de sérénité beaucoup
d'efficacité au fond aux arguments
parfois fallacieux vous avez pu
développer et remercier Monsieur le
Ministre ici qui a fait preuve d'une
constance d'une pédagogie d'une
connaissance des dossiers que j'ai
admiré moi-même je pense que c'est le
muscles vous êtes un grand militante à
faire je vous en remercie
monsieur le président
la parole et vous venez d'entendre
François Patriat le président du groupe
RDPI le groupe de la majorité
présidentielle au Sénat dans
l'explication de vote finale sur cette
réforme des retraites les sénateurs au
terme de ces explications vont à
s'exprimer sur et bien l'ensemble de
cette réforme des retraites on écoute la
sénatrice communiste Cathy a poursu poli
la droite sénatoriale s'apprête à voter
cette réforme scélérate de recul de
l'âge de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
elle s'apprête à le faire main dans la
main avec le gouvernement et laisse
sénatrice et sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle vous avez pu parvenir à
ce moment du vote malgré la contrainte
de l'article 47 1 de la Constitution
parce que vous avez ensemble
gouvernement et majorité sénatoriale
usé de toutes les procédures
réglementaires et constitutionnelle
possible et inimaginable pour accélérer
les débats en censurant l'opposition de
la Golf sénatoriale
vous avez bloqué la démocratie le
blocage c'est vous ce projet de loi est
fondamental pour des millions de nos
concitoyens et de nos concitoyennes ils
veulent deux années de retraite en bonne
santé à ces travailleurs et travailleurs
qui quel que soit leur corps de métier
aspirent au repos ce projet de loi c'est
aussi la nouvelle attaque contre les
régimes spéciaux régimes pionniers qui
concerne des professions rudes votez la
fin du régime spécial des électriciens
et gaziers au moment où ils sont
mobilisés dans des conditions très
difficiles suite aux intempéries de ces
dernières 48 heures est une insulte pour
eux monsieur le ministre vous vous êtes
empêtrés pour faire prendre des vessies
pour des lanternes à votre peuple en
affichant des avancées sur leur carrière
longue ou sur le revenu minimum de 1200
euros avancés qui s'avère lilliputienne
et même inconsistante
vous avez multiplié dissimulations et
contre vérité pour tenter de rendre
acceptable votre texte vous avez échoué
la toile de fond reste la même et
personne n'est dupe vous voulez reculer
l'âge de départ à la retraite ce projet
de loi vous l'avez aggravé mesdames et
messieurs de la droite sénatoriale
comment ne pas évoquer l'introduction
par vos soins du verre dans le fruit des
retraites avec votre amendement sur la
capitalisation vous avez tombé le masque
votre choix c'est celui des fonds de
tension vous vous attaquer au régime par
répartition pour rendre de fait
obligatoire le recours aux assurances
privées nous l'avons dit d'entrer vous
violez la Constitution à double titre
d'une part en empêchant le débat
parlementaire et d'autre part en mettant
le principe républicain reconnu par le
préambule de la Constitution de 1946
issu du programme du Conseil National de
la Résistance
mais pour vous monsieur le ministre il
n'y a pas de principe votre priorité
n'est pas leur bien-être c'est d'éviter
de demander au plus riche et au patronat
de payer de ne pas mettre la main à la
poche parce que finalement il n'y a que
ça qui vous intéresse avec vos nouveaux
alliés de la droite sénatoriale vous
avez refusé d'examiner sérieusement nos
propositions
alternatives au financement oui il est
possible de rétablir la retraite à 60
ans véritable projet de justice sociale
à l'heure ou des progrès scientifiques
et technologiques
partagez les richesses partagez le
travail pensez à un monde plus juste
humain qui par un projet de
transformation sociale et écologique est
une alternative complète à votre projet
libéral projet d'un vieux monde où seul
la concurrence et le profit ne trouve
grâce à vos yeux ce projet il grandit
dans notre peuple que vous le vouliez ou
pas il grandit en Europe et dans
l'esprit de tous les peuples du monde
cette réforme des retraites c'est une
réforme rétrograde un projet de classe
contre classe pour l'imposer vous avez
donc choisi le coup de force
anti-démocratique
tous les moyens sont bons pour vous du
détournement initial de la Constitution
pour corseter le débat à l'application
du blog bloqué au Sénat votre choix
c'est l'autoritarisme Emmanuel Macron
refuse de recevoir les syndicats Unis
quand votre projet affirme dans une
dérive
bonapartiste assumée ne parlez qu'au
peuple mais enfin écoutez justement le
peuple qui est vend debout vent debout
quand votre réforme écoutez-le une fois
pour toutes le coup de force
anti-démocratique avec le non vote de
l'Assemblée nationale et le vote bloqué
le vote forcer du Sénat rend illégitime
cette réforme des retraites
rétrograde monsieur Macron veut
s'adresser au peuple
qu'il le fasse en organisant un
référendum avec cette question Êtes-vous
pour ou contre le recul à 64 ans de
l'âge de départ à la retraite pour
ouvrir cette porte de sortie
démocratique à la grave très grave crise
sociale et politique que nous vivons
retirez votre projet
retirez-le avant que la colère populaire
ne vous atteigne cette réforme est
illégitime je le redis nous l'avons dit
sans cesse sur les bancs de la gauche
comme le brandissait une dame cet
après-midi à la manifestation à Paris
sur une pancarte
je suis fatigué
laissez-moi laissez-nous enfin le temps
d'être heureux et heureuse alors retrait
de cette réforme à 64 ans et croyez-nous
croyez moi nous irons jusqu'au bout
la parole est à notre collègue Henri
Cabanel et voilà pour cette prise de
parole de la sénatrice communiste Katia
poursu poli dans l'explication de votre
finale au Sénat sur la réforme des
retraites vous allez maintenant écouter
le sénateur du groupe RDSE au Sénat le
groupe radical au Sénat Henri Cabanel
les affaires sociales madame et monsieur
le rapporteur
mes chers collègues
mon groupe est déçu déçu par cette
mascarade de débat
les yeux étaient rivés sur le Sénat nous
aurions pu montrer la raison la
conscience aux Français qui attendaient
beaucoup de notre assemblée les Français
qui pour la sauvegarde du régime à
répartition était essentiel après le
spectacle désolant de l'Assemblée
nationale nous aurions pu sortir
ressortir grandi
naïvement j'y croyais mais le scénario
était écrit d'avance les uns et les
autres se rejetant la responsabilité de
cet échec pourtant pourtant il y a eu de
moments rares trop rares de débats
intéressants
bien sûr notre Constitution ainsi que
notre règlement prévoit tous les cas de
figures pour l'examen des textes de loi
bien sûr nous avons des droits pour
défendre des amendements
mais que dire des dizaines de prises de
parole sur des rappels au règlement ou
sur des dizaines d'amendements
identiques bien avant l'article 17 sur
l'âge de départ à la retraite ce n'est
pas comme cela que l'on fait entendre
nos voix ni qu'on gagne des voies bien
sûr le gouvernement a des droits aussi
pour recourir aux 44 3 nous privant
ainsi de débats dans la deuxième partie
le scénar aussi à travers son règlement
mais devait-on en arriver là que dire de
la méthode sur le véhicule législatif
sur le rejet de la réforme par tous les
partenaires sociaux sans oublier les
nombreuses personnes dans les rues
nous avions aussi des devoirs ceux de ne
pas priver les Français d'un débat
d'idée de leur offrir la possibilité
d'améliorer ce texte sur des sujets
primordiaux je passe aux aménagements
pour les carrières longues à
l'amélioration des droits à pension pour
les femmes les étudiants les sportifs
les personnes en situation d'handicap ou
encore pour tous ceux qui s'engagent à
cet égard j'espère que l'amendement de
mon groupe en faveur des pompiers
volontaires résistera comme bout de
beaucoup d'autres que nous avons pu
malgré tout faire adopter dans le
brouillard de ses débats
pour aller encore plus au fond de tout
cela était-il trop demandé de tout
simplement débattre avec une envie
véritable d'aller d'avancer d'aller
jusqu'au bout du texte notre devoir
était de montrer notre sincérité
à mon avis nous n'avons pas atteint ces
objectifs loin de là l'image est
désastreuse et notre responsabilité je
pense et collégiale
et comment avec cela réconcilier les
Français avec la politique ils sont
complètement écœurés par ces méthodes et
complètement déconnectée on le serait à
moins
ces stratagèmes de vieilles politiques
ne serviront pas à notre corps à notre
noble cause la colère et la déception
génère des votes extrême et certains
sont tombés dans le piège de la théâtre
réalisation qui ne leur a servi qui
donnera qui ne leur sera d'aucun
bénéfice pardon car aujourd'hui le parti
qui gagne et celui de la tension
souvenons-nous tous des dernières
élections
ce qui s'est passé au Parlement sur ce
texte laissera des traces c'est bien
dommage car je suis certain qu'au fond
tous ensemble nous sommes tous d'accord
pour dire que notre démocratie vieux
vaut mieux que cela
au bout de ce tunnel de discussion
chacun des membres de bons groupes
votera se lancer se lancer convictions
et je voudrais aussi remercier tous mes
collègues qui pendant ces 10 jours ont
été présents ainsi que remercier tous
nos collaborateurs
pour ma part je crois toujours à la
nécessité d'une réforme la stratégie
d'évite même mise en œuvre depuis 10
jours n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux
reculer pour mieux sauter ne présage en
rien de bon car cette hypothéqué
l'avenir dans notre système de retraite
par répartition
menacée par une logique démographique
implacable un système auquel sont
attachés nos concitoyens faut-il le
rappeler aussi il est au cœur du pacte
social de notre République il mérite
d'être sauvé son équilibre ainsi que ses
partenaires fondamentaux dont celui très
important de la solidarité je vous
remercie si chers collègues
je vais donner la parole au président
Claude malurer pour le groupe et les
sénateurs sont en train de procéder à
l'explication de votre finale sur la
réforme des retraites chaque groupe
politique s'exprime et ensuite et bien
elle est sénateurs vont au terme d'un
débat de 10 jours voter sur cette
réforme des retraites on écoute Claude
malurey le président du groupe les
indépendants au Sénat
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame la Présidente de la
Commission madame la rapporteur général
monsieur le rapporteur spécial mes chers
collègues
en 1981 le premier président de gauche
de la Cinquième République a voulu faire
croire aux Français que la situation de
notre pays nous permettait d'abaisser
l'âge de la retraite à 60 ans que nous
serions des précurseurs et que les
autres pays développés ne tarderaient
pas à nous emboîter le pas 10 ans plus
tard après le déclassement économique
des années 80 et après que nos voisins
européens aient choisi le chemin
exactement inverse qui consiste à
augmenter l'âge de la retraite parfois
jusqu'à 67 ans un autre homme de gauche
qui n'était pas lui un démagogue Michel
Rocca expliquait qu'il fallait d'urgence
revenir en arrière mais ajouter que ce
retour à la réalité ferait chuter quatre
gouvernements il n'était pas loin de la
vérité
depuis 30 ans plusieurs gouvernements
ont tenté de réformer le système pour
éviter les déficites abisseaux qui
s'annonçaient certains ont échoué comme
en 95 d'autres ont réussi au prix d'une
part d'une impopularité certaine d'autre
part d'une limitation forcée de leurs
objectifs qui n'ont jamais permis de
résoudre le problème du déficit
structurel dû à la chute permanente du
nombre de cotisants par rapport à celui
des retraités ce Vulcan en 93 en 2003 en
2010 et pour la première fois et pour la
dernière fois pardon en 2013 sous la
présidence de François Hollande je suis
d'ailleurs surpris que ceux qui ont
défendu à l'époque cette réforme en
constatant son inévitable impopularité
et en sachant pertinemment qu'elle ne
résoudrait les problèmes que pour un
temps soit aujourd'hui dans le camp des
adversaires acharnés de la réforme
actuelle comme s'ils ignoraient sa
nécessité
[Applaudissements]
on dit souvent que l'on peut faire dire
aux chiffres ce que l'on veut mais
lorsque l'on parle d'un déficit pour le
système de retraite de 150 milliards
cumulés d'ici 10 ans comment nier la
nécessité d'une nouvelle réforme s'il
est un objectif sur lequel nous pouvons
tous nous mettre d'accord c'est la
préservation de notre régime par
répartition et ce n'est pas en laissant
croître le déficit que l'avenir de ce
système sera assuré diminuer les
pensions est inacceptables dans un
contexte où l'inflation s'installe
durablement et range le pouvoir d'achat
augmenter les cotisations est
inenvisageable dans un pays déjà
médailles d'or au championnats du monde
des prélèvements obligatoires reste donc
le report de l'âge légal de la de départ
à la retraite c'est la solution retenue
par ce projet de loi et c'est celle qui
nous paraît la meilleure non pas la plus
agréable ou la plus populaire mais la
meilleure en tout cas la plus juste et
la moins mauvais pendant de très longues
heures nous avons entendu à noséames
plusieurs groupes ne s'est assemblés
ravâché d'autres pistes de financement
un inventaire à la Prévert de taxes
supplémentaires augmentation de la CSG
contribution exceptionnelle sur ceci ou
cela taxe sur les robots et j'en passe
et des meilleurs mais au fond rien de
cela ne devrait nous surprendre nous
écoutons souvent ces mêmes propositions
lors de l'examen du budget cette fois le
prétexte et le financement du système de
retraite mais l'objectif reste toujours
le même taxer plus
notre système de retraite doit pouvoir
s'équilibrer par les cotisations
prélevées sur les salaires il a été
construit ainsi il doit évoluer avec la
réalité et non pas contre elle bien sûr
il est nécessaire de prendre en compte
les situations particulières des
Français ce débat au Parlement était
l'opportunité d'amander le texte en
étant force de proposition c'est
pourquoi notre groupe apporté des
amendements pour mieux protéger les plus
précaires de nos concitoyens de tenir
compte des carrières longues et de ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt de
ceux qui exercent un travail pénible
tous les jours et qui doivent avoir le
droit de partir plus tôt en retraite des
mers dans la carrière est parfois
pénalisée par leur maternité alors même
que la natalité est un des facteurs clés
de notre modèle par répartition des
aidants qui vivent parfois des
situations extrêmement difficiles et qui
doivent être encouragés ou encore des
pompiers volontaires qui risquent leur
vie et qui méritent notre reconnaissance
malheureusement
une partie du débat a été confisqué par
la gauche
sans avoir su convaincre nos concitoyens
au cours des derniers scrutins
sans avoir su proposer des solutions
viables pour notre système de retraite
elle n'a cherché qu'à retarder nos
débats en déposant plus de 8000
amendements et sous amendements en
déposant des dizaines voire des
centaines d'amendements de suppression
sur chaque article en déposant des
amendements identiques qui déclinaient à
même dispositif en ne changeant qu'un
seul chiffre en passant des heures
entières de séances à faire des rappels
au règlement qui n'en n'étaient pas
vraiment les groupes de gauche ont
choisi une stratégie d'obstruction
délibérée et constante avec pour seul
objectif la non d'adoption du texte ils
ne s'en sont d'ailleurs pas cachés je
suis navré de devoir le rappeler mais il
n'y a pas en démocratie de minorité de
blocage ce n'est pas parce qu'une
minorité refuse de voter un texte
qu'elle doit empêcher la majorité de le
faire et je voudrais aussi rappeler que
dans une démocratie la loi ne se fait
pas dans la rue mais au Parlement
[Applaudissements]
et au Parlement la grande hypocrisie de
ce débat c'est que la gauche s'indine
aujourd'hui de l'utilisation de
l'article 44-3 de notre loi fondamentale
alors même qu'elle y a allègrement
recouru pour faire adopter la réforme
Touraine qu'elle portait dans 2013 et 9
fois au cours du mandat de François
Hollande nous
ignorons pas que cette réforme est
impopulaire et pour cause elle existe
des efforts supplémentaires de tous les
Français alors même qu'ils ont
fournissent déjà beaucoup mais c'est
précisément parce qu'il s'agit d'une
réforme aussi nécessaire que délicate
que le Parlement se devait aller au bout
de son examen ce n'est pas en fuyant nos
responsabilités que nous ferons honneur
à notre mandat et je voudrais après les
orateurs qui m'ont précédé remercier
notre président les ministres qui sont
restés au banc pendant ces 10 jours la
présidente de la commission la
rapporteur général le rapporteur spécial
et tous nos collègues dont le dans la
patience a été mise parude épreuve et
enfin l'ensemble du personnel du Sénat
qui a participé à tout ce jour de
discussion l'avenir des français est en
jeu le texte que nous examinons depuis
plusieurs jours est essentiel à bien des
égards car c'est la survie du régime par
répartition qui est en cause parce qu'il
s'agit d'un projet de loi nécessaire
responsable et juste notre groupe votera
en faveur de cette réforme merci
monsieur le président
mais c'était la prise de parole de
Claude malurey le président du groupe
les indépendants au Sénat dans
l'explication de vote finale au Sénat
sur cette réforme des retraites chaque
groupe politique prend la parole et
ensuite les sénateurs vont s'exprimer
vont voter sur l'ensemble de cette
réforme des retraites on écoute Raymonde
ponce à la sénatrice écologiste cette
réforme des retraites
qu'elle n'a quinquennat car à travers
elle c'est le système productif et le
contrat social qui sont en jeu c'est le
travail l'emploi mais aussi les
conditions de travail c'est le temps
libéré du travail subordonné la place
des activités non marchande ce sont
toutes les problématiques sociales qui
sont ici convoquées l'espérance de vie
en bonne santé le handicap la part du
travail dans la répartition des
richesses
l'invalidité l'inaptitude c'est
l'exclusion sociale la précarité la
pauvreté qui ont été questionnées c'est
la place du prendre soin de l'autonomie
des aidants c'est la place des services
publics et les conséquences de la baisse
des effectifs et du gels du point
d'indice des fonctionnaires c'est la
place des femmes des personnes immigrées
et plus largement la question des
discriminations sur le marché dans
l'emploi qui sont mis en avant la
retraite ne peut être traitée avec une
règle de trois budgétaires c'est un
projet de société ces questions aurait
mérité d'être plus questionner
interroger faire le l'objet de
controverse or nous nous sommes heurtés
un mur anti-démocratique pour bâillonner
la minorité parlementaire d'abord par le
silence d'abord par le silence c'est la
passivité de la droite sur nos
propositions d'amendements pour résoudre
le problème des ressources puisque le
problème nous le rappelons ce n'est pas
la dynamique des dépenses de retraite
puis du 47 ans ou 44,3 de la
constitution du 42 9 de notre règlement
la mobilisation de tous les outils
possibles pour imposer l'examen express
de nos amendements après le recours
abusif aux irrecevabilité après le
retrait d'amendement de la majorité de
droite pour faire tomber les nôtres puis
l'interdit d'expliquer nos votes dans un
débat dès dans un sénat dévitalisé de
toutes les confrontations les arguments
et ceci ceci pour aboutir le plus vite
possible au vote seul enjeu de la droite
et du gouvernement un Satan au plus vite
la collusion de la droite sénatoriale et
du gouvernement pour gagner une course
de vitesse face à une mobilisation qui
monte croissante inédite déterminée une
mobilisation d'une majorité de Français
de la quasi-totalité des actifs déjà des
femmes de toutes les catégories
socio-professionnelles et surtout de
l'ensemble des syndicats de salariés
unis dans une intercer syndicale
historique et faisant du refus du recul
de l'âge d'ouverture des droits de la
retraite à la retraite une question non
négociable une course de vitesse pour
plier le débat car jamais jamais un
texte n'a été autant un populaire la
pièce qui s'est joué au Sénat créa
précédent et est dangereuse pour
l'avenir de la démocratie parlementaire
et pour la confiance de la population
envers la démocratie représentative
ce qui s'est produit ne profitera aucun
de ses acteurs ni à la droite qui croit
avoir enfin obtenu la victoire de leurs
projets régressif ni au gouvernement qui
se croit libéré d'une bataille alors
qu'il a perdu tout soutien dans la
population et donc toutes légitimité
sociale et morales toutes les victoires
arrachées par le pouvoir au corps
défendant du peuple sont rendus
possibles par un glissement autoritaire
qui nous éloigne des principes dont le
corps politique se revendique pourtant
la liberté et la démocratie la façon
dont le gouvernement impose son projet
avec la complicité de la majorité
conservatrice du Sénat annonce une aire
iribérale où l'extrême droite ne sera
que la seule bénéficiaire car nous le
savons cette réforme antisociale des
retraites n'était pas nécessaire et le
déficit y a été construit par la non
volonté d'y allouer des ressources
l'ensemble de nos propositions ont été
balayées alors qu'elles étaient juste
socialement et durable tant sur le plan
financier environnemental les 18 les 18
milliards ne seront générés que par le
monde du travail nullement sur le
capital nullement sur les très hauts
patrimoine l'unement sur les
bénéficiaires depuis 2017 du désarmement
fiscal uniquement sur les travailleurs
travailleuses et des travailleurs qui
verront s'éloigner l'horizon de leur vie
hors travail ces années de travail
supplémentaires ne sont plus permise par
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie
elles sont prises sur la durée de la
retraite qui diminue désormais
on cessera alors le travail plus proche
de la mort c'est peut-être ce qu'ils
fonde inconsciemment la force du refus
ces années de plus sont prises sur
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé ou
prolonge une situation de pauvreté de
précarité pour faire passer cela nous
avons assisté à une exaltation du
travail comme si tout travail était pas
construction par définition émancipateur
et comme si refusait de le prolonger
sans fin était la négation de sa place
venant d'un gouvernement qui nie la
pénibilité du travail rien de nouveau à
défaut de changer les choses on change
les mots pour les maçons les aides à
domicile les chauffeurs de bus les
égoutiers les professeurs les soignants
les agriculteurs les employés les
ouvriers le travail et surtout à partir
d'un certain âge peut être si une
souffrance qui abime les corps et les
esprits et toutes les statistiques
montrent que cela et de plus en plus
vrai
or qu'avons-nous pour elle et eux dans
ce texte à part un index non
contraignant que le Conseil
constitutionnel risque d'exclure comme
cavalier social quand on mesure
d'atténuation de la brutalité de cette
réforme elles ont été évoquées dans un
combat sans contradictoire et c'était
mieux vu les mensonge quant aux trois
milliards annoncés pour l'incapacité par
permanente c'est un mensonge inexiste
pas puisque rien ne change sur ce point
vous votez cette réforme contre le
peuple vous votez cette réforme au nom
de l'avenir avec un logiciel du passé le
sens de l'histoire c'était et cela reste
la retraite à 60 ans c'est la baisse du
temps de travail et la transformation de
notre modèle de production et de
consommation c'est la reconnaissance des
activités selon leur utilité sociale et
non au profit de la croissance sans fin
de la richesse de quelques heures nous
ne voterons pas cette réforme pas
uniquement pour les raisons que nous
avons développé mais parce que nous
avons un autre projet celui de
l'écologie sociale ce soir la bataille
au Sénat aboutit à un vote de la droite
pour sauver le gouvernement mais la
bataille contre cette loi continue et
autant qu'il le faudra la gauche les
écologistes l'amèneront jusqu'au retrait
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président kaner monsieur le
Président Monsieur les ministres
cette réforme a été présentée merci de
la parole monsieur le Président cette
réforme a été présenté comme la merde de
toutes les réformes et vous savez que
pour nous en tout cas elle constituera
une
régression sociale pour plusieurs
millions de nos concitoyens qui seront
malheureusement à payer un impôt mais un
impôt sur leur vie de retraite c'est une
informe donc essentielle mes chers
collègues et nous pensons au nom des
trois groupes de gauche ici présents et
mes collègues associés et compta et tous
les collègues ici présents 30
signataires demande l'application de
l'article 51 de notre règlement à savoir
que la présence dans l'enceinte du
palais de la majorité absolue des
sénateurs est nécessaire pour la
validité des votes sauf en matière de
fixation de l'ordre du jour donc
monsieur le Président je sollicite votre
part c'est cette constatation éventuelle
bien monsieur le président
s'il vous plaît
je suis saisi d'une demande écrite
monsieur le Président par vous-même de
vérification du corps en application de
l'article 51 aligné à 3 du règlement la
constatation du nombre des présents est
effectué sur la demande écrite de 30
sénateurs dont la présence doit être
constatée par appel nominal il va donc
être procédé à l'appel nominal des
signataires de la demande de
vérification du Corum et les huissiers
vont donc effectuer cet appel à vous
madame Cathy
Eliane assassy
chez David Assouline
Florence
Public Sénat le vote final au Sénat sur
la réforme des retraites avec un nouveau
rebondissement de la part de la gauche
sénatoriale les sénateurs de gauche qui
demande et bien à ce que soit compté le
nombre de sénateurs puisque c'est le
règlement du Sénat c'est ce petit livre
vert qui l'impose il faut qu'il y ait
une majorité absolue de sénateurs pour
que le vote sur un texte et donc sur
cette réforme de retraite soit valide
précisément il faut qu'il y ait au moins
175 sénateurs dans l'hémicycle allez on
va retrouver et bien Mathias Arès pour
en parler Mathias qui est dans la
tribune de l'hémicycle du Sénat c'est un
nouvel article du règlement du Sénat qui
est utilisé et on appelle ça et bien une
demande de Corum absolument Alexandre RD
il est là le règlement et c'est donc
l'article 51 alinéa 3 qui a donc été
demandé par le président socialiste
Patrick Canet il a donc demandé au
président Gérald de constater le corps
un malheur de quoi s'agit-il est bien le
président l'archet doit donc faire
doit donc constater que la majorité des
sénateurs sont présents dans l'enceinte
du palais pour que le vote soit jugé
valable cette demande de constatation du
Coran elle doit être signé par écrit par
30 sénateurs qui est donc doivent faire
parvenir au président du Sénat c'est 30
sénateurs qui ont donc été appelés par
les huissiers et donc le report du vote
aura lieu d'ici au moins une heure il
sera donc à ce moment-là valable même si
le Corum n'est pas constitué
effectivement Mathias alors on le
précise il y a un appel qui est en train
d'être mené dans l'hémicycle du Sénat
chaque sénateur est appelé par ordre
alphabétique et bien on va recevoir
pendant cet appel les différents
sénateurs les différents groupes
politiques qui ont participé à ce débat
de 10 jours sur la réforme des retraites
on reste bien sûr en direct sur Public
Sénat pour vous faire vivre ce vote
finale sur la réforme des retraites avec
et bien nouveau rebondissements et puis
la gauche inatoriale qui va rallonger un
petit peu plus ces débats sur la réforme
des retraites on va peut-être retrouver
Mathias Arès en tribune de l'hémicycle
du Sénat Mathias un mot sur le texte qui
va être voté par les sénateurs bien
écoutez c'est le texte qui était examiné
jusqu'ici à présent qui avait été amendé
par la droite c'est notoriale vous le
savez qui a notamment apporté des
améliorations solo notamment sur la
surcote des mers ou encore sur le CDI
senior jusqu'à l'activation vous le
savez à l'article 11 de ce vote bloqué
par le gouvernement à partir de ce
moment-là on a donc simplement continué
à défendre les amendements mais ce qui
sera soumis au vote et bien ce
simplement les amendements qui ont été
retenus par le gouvernement c'est donc
une version un peu remanier du texte par
la droite sanatoriale et avec je vous le
disais notamment ceux CDI senior ou
encore la surcote des mers voulues par
Bruno Retailleau mais pas totalement
notamment avec cette amendement de Bruno
retaillod sur les régimes spéciaux et la
fin du club de la côte de la clause du
grand-père qui n'a pas pu être mise dans
le texte puisque entre-temps le
gouvernement avait donc enclenché cette
procédure de votre bloqué Alexandre
merci beaucoup Mathias si on précise que
l'appel qui vient d'être réalisé
concerné les 30 signataires de cette
demande de commande
voilà il n'y a pas 36 signataires de
cette demande de couronne il y en a que
29 vient de préciser le président du
Sina Gérard Larcher ça veut dire que
cette demande de comment de Corum est
invalidé
place au vote sur cette réforme
je vais mettre au voile les articles 9 à
20 modifiés par les amendements adoptés
le Sénat à l'article 9 et se proposait
ou accepter par le gouvernement ainsi
que l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023
je rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 59 du règlement le scrutin
public et de droit
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 de notre règlement
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
le Sénat est en train actuellement de
voter sur l'ensemble de la réforme des
retraites par un scrutin public alors ce
que un public ça veut dire que les
sénateurs vont voter chacun sur leur
tablettes électronique et que vous
pourrez connaître le vote de chaque
sénateur sur cette réforme des retraites
sur le site internet du Sénat c'est un
moment important du débat parlementaire
sur cette réforme des retraites qui est
en train de se jouer la haute assemblée
qui après 10 jours de débats est en
train de se prononcer sur l'issue de
cette réforme des retraites sachant que
normalement la majorité de droite et du
centre du Sénat devrait l'adopter mais
il faudra regarder précisément le
résultat de ce vote ce que vont faire
chaque sénateur face à cette réforme des
retraites qui je le rappelle reportent
l'âge légal de départ à
64 ans les sénateurs qui ont adopté des
amendements qui adopté des modifications
sur ce texte pendant ces 10 jours de
débat des modifications qui ont été
gardées par le gouvernement même si le
gouvernement hier à la fin de ce débat a
déclencher la procédure du vote bloqué
l'article 44 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
pour et bien clôturer les débats et
retenir certains amendements triés sur
le volet finalement une un passage en
force au final par le gouvernement mais
un passage en force
plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin
votant 344
exprimé 3 sur 7 pour 195 contre 112 le
Sénat a adopté
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre dans deux secondes
mes chers collègues nous sommes parvenus
au terme de ce débat très dense dans
lequel chacun s'est exprimé depuis le
Jeudi de mars nous avons siégé 10 jours
et quasiment autant de nuit en continu
pour un total de plus de chanteurs de
débats
nous avons enregistré un nombre record
d'amendements du sous amendements
8900 au total
le débat a eu lieu à des bacs pu être
éclairés où chacun a pu affirmer sa
position sur chaque partie chaque apport
du sec sur l'article 7 qu'on peut
qualifier de cœur du réacteur dont nous
avons engagé la discussion le mardi 7
mars au soir nous avons eu 63 prises de
parole sur l'article avant la
présentation des 77 amendements de
suppression d'articles nous avons
débattu plus de 13 heures sur ce seul
article 7 les règles de procédure est
celle fixée par la Constitution
nous conduis à achever l'examen de ce
texte dans le délai de 15 jours un parti
au Sénat
par-delà nous divergences qui sont
profondes je crois que nous avons pu
mettre l'empreinte du Sénat sur ce texte
je Réal salué le travail approfondie
de madame le rapporteur général et du
rapporteur de la branche vieillesse et
de la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales
[Applaudissements]
parce que eux ils ont fait les senteurs
plus le travail en commission plus ce
travail préparatoire j'aurais salué le
travail de l'ensemble des membres de
votre commission madame la Présidente la
commission ainsi que celui des collègues
sénateurs de l'ensemble des groupes je
voudrais vous remercier Monsieur le
Ministre pour Monsieur les ministres
pour
votre présence tout au long de nos
débats ainsi que pour la pédagogie que
vous avez
démontré au cours de ce débat ce travail
va maintenant se poursuivre son chemin
en commission mixte paritaire avant de
nous revenir la semaine prochaine voilà
ce que je voulais vous dire en vous
remerciant mes chers collègues
permettez-moi de remercier
particulièrement les vices présidents du
Sénat qui ont été à l'attache et qui se
sont répartis dans leur vivacité
diversité c'est plus de 100 heures de
débat moi aussi je voudrais
associer l'ensemble j'allais dire
particulièrement du service législatif
et du service de la commission des
affaires sociales qui ont été vraiment
dans une tâche exceptionnelle
pour certains c'était leur baptême du
feu pour d'autres l'apogée presque d'un
premier étape de carrière en vous
souhaitant le meilleur chers madame pour
la suite en tous les cas je voulais vous
dire que j'ai le sentiment d'être le
président d'une institution qui a joué
son rôle et qu'il l'a joué avec
engagement responsabilité avec pour
seule ligne de crête quelle que soit nos
sentiments l'intérêt du pays et
l'intérêt des Français
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
vos mots mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs mesdames la présidente de la
commission mesdames messieurs mesdames
et messieurs le rapporteur trois mois à
mon tour d'abord pour vous dire que avec
mon collègue Franck Riester avec Gabriel
Attal qui était présent à nos côtés pour
les articles financiers je voudrais
adresser tous mes remerciements à Madame
la Présidente et Mesdames et monsieur le
rapporteur pour la qualité des relations
que nous avons entretenu pour les
travaux préparatoires les échanges ont
parfois été vifs sur l'importateur parce
que nous n'avons nous avions quelques
divergences et il en reste sur ce texte
mais je crois que nous avons fait cela
dans un climat constructif dans un
climat de travail et avec la volonté de
porter un texte et de faire en sorte que
chacun puisse se retrouver et espérer
qu'à la fin de tout ce processus le
texte soit adopté et qu'il puisse être
le meilleur possible je voudrais
remercier tous les sénateurs tous les
sénateurs qui ont participé à ce débat
des présidents de groupe et les
sénateurs parce que je pense que chaque
contribution a été utile que les groupes
ont pu faire valoir des positions les
sénateurs ont pu faire valoir des
positions et à travers ces positions à
travers les amendements qui ont été
adoptés le texte a pu être enrichi sur
la question des orphelins sur la
question des maires de famille sur la
question des agriculteurs des
sapeurs-pompiers du rachat de trimestre
ou encore des élus locaux je sais
combien madame la rapporteur pour avis
et particulièrement attaché nous avons
enrichi ce texte et nous avons je crois
espérer que la suite du débat
parlementaire et la commission mixte
paritaire les étapes qui suivront
permettent de l'enrichir encore pour que
ce texte puisse ainsi pour aussi son
chemin législatif la deuxième chose que
je voulais vous dire à vous tous et
peut-être à vous encore plus
particulièrement Monsieur le Président
c'est que beaucoup d'entre vous ont
peut-être pris un peu l'habitude de me
voir depuis quelques années au travers
des différentes fonctions que j'ai
exercé et beaucoup d'entre vous savent
que celle que j'ai toujours beaucoup de
plaisir à retrouver le Sénat débattre au
Sénat et que j'apprécie à la fois la
qualité de vos travaux mais aussi leur
calme et comme les sentiments comme le
plaisir
le plaisir intellectuel la satisfaction
intellectuelle sont des sentiments
relatifs qui se mesure toujours à
l'homme du déplaisir que l'on peut
connaître par ailleurs je l'ai encore
plus apprécié cette fois-ci
et enfin
et enfin monsieur le Président
permettez-moi de m'associer à vos mots
pour l'ensemble des services du Sénat
n'est peut-être pas la coutume mais je
vais à la fois saluer la qualité
l'intensité du travail mais aussi
remercier l'ensemble des services du
Sénat l'ensemble des agents pour la très
grande gentillesse avec laquelle ils
accueillent les membres du gouvernement
nos équipes combien ils peuvent aussi en
même temps qui vous accompagnent dans
leur fonction nous faciliter le travail
ici remercier l'ensemble des équipes qui
m'accompagnent sur ce texte évidemment
les services du ministère du Travail des
services du gouvernement mais vous
comprendrez que j'ai une attention toute
particulière pour mon cabinet ils ont un
engagement et un investissement que dont
je suis le témoin le plus privilégié et
qui est absolument absolument
remarquable et enfin dernier point pour
vous dire que je suis particulièrement
heureux parce que parlementaire depuis
2017 quand le Parlement vote et quand le
quand le Parlement légifère merci à tous
merci monsieur le ministre
merci messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues je vais lever la
séance
prochaine séance le mardi 14 mars 2023
14h30 pour la proposition de loi
organique visant à permettre à
Saint-Barthélémy de participer à
l'exercice de compétences de l'État la
séance est levée
et c'est l'information de la soirée le
Sénat vient de voter pour la réforme des
retraites après 10 jours de débat après
l'échec des débats à l'Assemblée
nationale et bien la majorité de droite
et du centre à voter pour ce projet de
loi de finance rectificative de la
sécurité sociale qui inclut cette
réforme des retraites et pour en parler
j'accueille sur ce plateau René Paul
Savary bonsoir bon vous êtes le
rapporteur de ce texte sénateur la
républicain votre réaction à ce vote
c'est une victoire pour pour la majorité
du Sénat c'est une victoire pour la
démocratie parce que c'est important que
les chambres des libèrent on a vu le
tableau
dommageable qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale donc il était
important que le Sénat cette deuxième
chambre qui travaille toujours les
textes en profondeur puissent voter
voilà on a eu des débats contradictoires
et il est important que la majorité
sénatoriale
affirme sa volonté de voir cette
dernière forme se réaliser d'autant que
c'était la réforme que la majorité de
droite et du centre du Sénat votaient
chaque année absolument c'est une
réforme sur lequel nous sommes qui nous
préoccupe depuis plus de 4 ans pourquoi
parce que nous pensons sincèrement qu'il
n'y a pas d'autres solutions pour
équilibrer notre système de retraite il
sera mis en péril c'est la raison pour
laquelle il est nécessaire il était
nécessaire et il sera nécessaire qu'il y
ait un effort partagé le plus
équitablement entre les Français de
façon à ce que l'on n'est pas diminué
les pensions ce qui diminuerait le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités ni connaît
pas à augmenter les cotisations ce qui
diminuerait le pouvoir d'achat des
actifs et faire en sorte qu'on équilibre
ce système il y va de l'avenir et de nos
enfants un mot sur les apports du Sénat
au terme de ces 10 jours de débat
qu'est-ce qu'on doit retenir de ce qui a
été voté par les sénateurs pour
améliorer cette réforme et ben écoutez
le Sénat amener des mesures de justice
sociale qui manquait à cette réforme
notamment pour la prise en compte des
maires de famille à travers une surcotte
à travers l'employabilité pour les
emplois du Seigneur à travers la prise
en compte de l'usure professionnelle et
ces différentes mesures permettront de
rendre cette réforme beaucoup plus
acceptable un mot sur la commission
mixte paritaire quels seront les lignes
rouges dans la négociation d'une version
commune de ce texte avec l'Assemblée
qu'est-ce que vous voulez garder nous
voulons garder nos dimensions sociales
de justice sociale qui a été amené par
le Sénat merci beaucoup René Paul Savary
d'être venu sur le plateau public final
alors que je vais accueillir dans
quelques instants le président du Sénat
Gérard Larcher au terme de ce vote
favorable de la Haute Assemblée en
faveur de la réforme des retraites on va
rappeler ce vote et bien il y a eu 195
votes pour 112 votre compte de sénateur
sur cette réforme de retraite et
j'accueille sur ce plateau le président
du Sénat Gérard Larcher bonsoir bonsoir
merci de venir sur le plateau de Public
Sénat d'abord votre réaction gère à
l'archet au terme de ces 10 jours de
débat ça y est et bien l'une des deux
Chambres du Parlement a voté cette
réforme de retraite je crois que le
Sénat a rempli sa mission
constitutionnelle
des avant l'ouverture des débats j'avais
dit que je souhaitais vraiment
profondément que nous ayons un débat aux
alliions au bout du débat et au
Parlement après le temps du débat on
délibère et on vote
je crois que c'est une responsabilité
majeure et c'est la responsabilité
du président d'une chambre dans un
parlement bi caméra
la seconde des choses c'est que nous
avons
par notre organisation des débats permis
qu'il y ait plus de senteurs de débats
je dois dire alors que nous n'avions que
15 jours alors que l'Assemblée nationale
a 20 jours et sans esprit de concurrence
nous avons presque débattu 30 heures de
plus que l'Assemblée nationale et
examiner les 20 articles de ce texte
au fond le vote de ce soir c'est la
conclusion d'une démarche engagée depuis
plus de 4 ans au Sénat dans une
réflexion de la commission des affaires
sociales
qui depuis quatre ans proposé de
réformer le système de retraite par
répartition pour le sauver pour le
préserver et le cœur du réacteur de ce
texte c'était l'article 7 sur le report
à 64 ans pour lequel j'ai rappelé le
nombre d'interventions de présentation
d'amendement le total c'est plus de 130
donc il y a eu un débat extrêmement
approfondie sur le cœur du réacteur et a
eu des votes
il va suite à ce vote avoir une
négociation dans ce qu'on appelle la
commission mixte paritaire entre cette
sénateur sept députés finalement un
dialogue entre la droite et le
gouvernement pour avoir et bien un
accord sur ce texte quels sont les
lignes rouges du Sénat sur cette réforme
des retraites d'abord la CP va avoir
lieu sur le texte du Sénat et non pas le
texte du Gouvernement imaginons que nous
n'ayons pas j'allais dire assurer notre
fonction
CMP aurait eu lieu sur le texte du
Gouvernement sans les apports qui ont
été les apports du Sénat je pense
notamment un certain nombre d'apports
sur les seniors sur l'assurance
vieillesse des aidants sur ce qui a pu
obtenu aussi au cours des débats je
pense pour les professeurs des écoles
pour les sapeurs-pompiers il va avoir
lieu aussi sur des questions aussi
importantes que par exemple la prise en
compte la prise en compte de l'usure
professionnelle de l'incapacité
professionnelle tous ces jugés là le
Sénat va les porter devant la commission
mixte paritaire
commission Bleach paritaire s'est a lieu
ouvert de débat entre 7 sénateurs cette
députée pour aboutir un texte qui devra
être présenté en suite
au Sénat puis à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est le chemin normal dans une
démocratie parlementaire la première
ministre Elisabeth borne a réagi à ce
vote et elle a dit que il existait une
majorité au Parlement en faveur de cette
réforme des retraites après des
soubresauts notamment l'Assemblée
nationale autour des députés LR est-ce
que vous dites ça y est les républicains
sont au côté du gouvernement sur cette
réforme je vais pas parler à la place
des députés de l'Assemblée nationale je
crois que le Sénat apporte un texte qui
reprend les préoccupations les
préoccupations qui ont été exprimées je
pense aussi à la question des petites
retraites je pense à la question des
carrières longues mais n'oublions pas
il y a une étude de très importante de
l'Institut des politiques publiques qui
a démontré que le sujet ce n'était pas
uniquement les carrières longues c'est
dans quelles conditions dans quelles
conditions arriver à un homme et une
femme après sa période de travail pour
envisager sa retraite dans les
meilleures conditions et ça c'est un
apport du Sénat c'est un mot sur la
forme de ces débats et la décision hier
du gouvernement d'utiliser la procédure
dite du vote bloqué est-ce que ce n'est
pas un échec démocratique quand même non
parce que ça s'appelle le vote unique
et donc on s'est exprimé par un vote
mais je rappelle que jusqu'à l'article 9
et débat avait lieu ils ont eu lieu dans
une forme différente
mais ils ont eu lieu et il y a eu je
dois dire des débats des temps de parole
des écoutes sur chacun des amendements
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président du
Sénat d'être venu sur notre plateau
après ce vote de la Haute Assemblée en
faveur de la réforme des retraites et
justement on va retrouver Mathias arez
en tribune de l'hémicycle du Sénat
Mathias qu'est-ce qu'on peut retenir du
texte qui a été voté au final par les
sénateurs bien écoutez Alexandre ce
qu'on peut retenir c'est que c'est un
texte qui a été en partie remanier par
la droite sénatoriale on le savait ce
texte on l'annonçait depuis plusieurs
semaines Bruno Retailleau en été le
premier à le dire cette réforme c'était
la leur donc oui les sénateurs ont
apporté leurs pattes sur leur tête sur
ce texte notamment avec la surcotte des
mers de famille ou encore sur les
rachats de trimestres pour les stages ou
encore l'employabilité des seniors avec
le CDI senior on le savait René Paul
Savary l'avait annoncé il voulait
apporter à cette réforme une touche un
peu moins brutale un peu l'adoucir
seulement voilà et bien le Sénat n'a pas
pu aller beaucoup plus loin dans ses
apports sur ce texte puisque à l'article
9 le gouvernement a décidé d'activer une
arme constitutionnelle à savoir
l'article 44 à Linéa 3 la l'article dit
également du vote bloqué qui empêche les
sénateurs d'amender le texte sauf les
amendements que retiens le gouvernement
c'est donc un vote unique qui a eu lieu
à l'instant avec donc les apports du
Sénat jusqu'à l'article 9 et à partir de
l'article 9 jusqu'à l'article 20 c'était
donc la version du gouvernement qui a
été soumis ce soir au sénateur merci
beaucoup Mathias si on continue à vous
faire vivre les réactions à ce vote du
Sénat sur la réforme des retraites
j'accueille sur ce plateau François
Patriat bonsoir vous êtes président du
groupe RDPI au Sénat on le précise c'est
le groupe de la ont été présidentielle
c'est une victoire justement pour la
majorité présidentielle se vote du Sénat
parlons pas de victoire parlons de
textes de loi nécessaire d'un vote de
responsabilité et d'un autre
d'efficacité et dans votre de justice et
d'équilibre ça ce soir donc le président
de la République s'est engagé
courageusement pendant la campagne
électorale à faire cette réforme elle a
été le fruit d'une très longue
concertation personne n'a été baïonné
pendant le débat au Sénat on aboutit un
texte ce soir à votre ce soir qui est
clair qui montre que ce qui est juste ce
qui est juste soit ça n'est pas tant de
demander des efforts ça tout le monde le
demande à tout le monde c'est vrai c'est
difficile ce qui est juste c'est
d'assurer pour les générations futures
une retraite descente et une dette en
moins pour la France et ça aujourd'hui
quoi que ce soit c'est la connais est-ce
que ce n'est pas aussi une victoire
politique pour la droite on le rappelle
il n'y a pas eu de vote à l'Assemblée
nationale et finalement les sénateurs de
la républicains ont imposé leur texte
alors d'abord je modère un peu ce propos
le texte qui voter ce soir c'est le
texte du Gouvernement et la majeure
partie du texte 90% c'est le texte du
Gouvernement aujourd'hui ce soir
j'entends la droite dire c'est le texte
des républicains non il y a eu quatre
amendements majeurs des républicains qui
ont été repris un sur la surcote pour
les femmes pour les femmes à 63 64 ans
un sur le C sur le CDI pour les seniors
et deux autres pour à la fois les
parents d'enfants handicapés et pour la
carrière et pour la retraite progressive
bon mais c'est ce sont des âges ou au
texte que le gouvernement a bien voulu
accepter de même qu'il avait accepté
après négociation Astro pas de 65 à 64
ce que l'ensemble de ce qu'on appelle
tout le stock des retraités soient pris
dans les 1200 euros de retraite mais
c'est un test c'est le texte de la
majorité donc ce n'est pas une victoire
de républicains c'est une victoire ce
soir de la France pour son avenir alors
moi sur l'avenir de la mobilisation on a
vu une manifestation aujourd'hui plus
faible et précédente est-ce que vous
pensez que ce premier vote au Parlement
justement ça va diminuer l'ampleur de
cette mobilisation ce que je crois c'est
que on nous a fait croire à l'apocalypse
on nous a dit que la France allait être
à l'arrêt que l'économie allait être
bloquée que tout toute la France on
pourrait plus agir travailler et se
déplacer on a vu que je m'en félicite ce
scénario n'est pas arrivé ce que je
crois aujourd'hui c'est que les Français
ont montré dans un sondage d'aujourd'hui
c'est que 8 sur 10 pense que la réforme
sera votée et qu'elle sera appliquée
parce que même si ça leur est difficile
de l'entendre même si il travaillait
plus il t'admettre que cette vraie forme
elle est à la fois nécessaire et juste
vous êtes confiant sur l'avenir de cette
réforme merci beaucoup François Patriat
d'être venu sur le plateau de Public
Sénat après ce vote du Sénat en faveur
de la réforme des retraites on va
retrouver rapidement mathiasarès en
tribune de l'hémicycle et puis après on
accueillera Bruno Retailleau en plateau
Mathias oui
je voulais évoquer avec vous Alexandre
ce vote bloqué donc qui a été qui a été
mise en place par le gouvernement c'est
donc l'article 44 alinéa 3 2 la
Constitution c'est une arme qui avait
été longtemps mis de côté puisqu'elle
est assez impopulaire si je peux vous
lire les termes c'est si le gouvernement
le demande l'assemblée saisie donc ici
le Sénat se prononce par un seul vote
sur tout ou partie du texte en
discussion en ne retenant que les
amendements proposés ou accepter par le
gouvernement donc cette ce mécanisme
connu comme le vote bloqué est une
disposition qui ne dépend de rien
d'autre que de la volonté du ministre
Olivier du sobre qui a donc décidé de
l'activer à partir de l'article 9 la
dernière fois qu'elle avait été utilisée
au Sénat c'était en 2010 sur justement
une autre réforme des retraites celle
qui était alors portée par le
gouvernement de François Fillon cette
ce mécanisme qui permet quand même de
faire gagner beaucoup de temps on a pu
le voir ici puisque et bien il n'y avait
plus d'explications de vote à la fin de
chaque article il n'y avait plus non
plus de scrutin public ça a permis
vraiment d'accélérer les débats tout en
privant certains sénateurs d'amendement
fort on l'a vu d'ailleurs avec le
président le président du groupe LR
Bruno retaillon Retailleau qui a donc
été privé de son amendement pour la
suppression de la clause du grand-père
Alexandre et bien justement on accueille
sur ce plateau Bruno Retailleau le
président du groupe les républicains au
Sénat bonsoir bonsoir première réaction
à ce vote du Sénat en faveur de la
réforme des retraites doubles victoires
pour la droite double victoire non c'est
pas d'abord une victoire pour la droite
sénatérielle d'abord c'est une victoire
je pense pour notre institution le Sénat
on a vu dans les conditions dans
lesquelles s'est déroulé le débat le
pseudo débat l'Assemblée nationale ça a
été une adification une guignolisation
ici les débats ont été rugueux mais ils
ont été malgré tout respectueux et
surtout surtout sur tout le Sénat à
voter ce soir la gauche par une
obstruction très méthodique mais très
massive à tenter d'empêcher le vote
parce que elle a été mauvaise perdante
elle savait à l'avance ça défaites et
par conséquent l'obstruction lui servait
de manœuvre de retardement voire même de
blocage du vote et ça ça n'est pas
démocratique donc le fait que on est
plus voter c'est fondamental l'autre
victoire c'est pour les retraités
d'aujourd'hui et de demain le régime par
répartition si on veut le sauvegarder
c'est un bien commun il y a quelques
efforts à faire si on fait pas ses
efforts on le fait exploser et ce sera
au détriment des plus modestes je
rappelle simplement une chose c'est
qu'en 2030 quand va la réforme va
s'appliquer pleinement la France sera le
pays en Europe qui verra un départ à la
retraite le plus précoce c'est ça la
vérité Bruno retaille alors mercredi il
va y avoir une négociation entre le
Sénat l'Assemblée nationale pour tomber
d'accord sur une version commune de
cette réforme des retraites qu'elles
vont être les lignes rouges de la
majorité du Sénat pour écrire cette
réforme des retraites on veut garder
l'essentiel de nos acquis un maximum de
nos acquis évidemment la surcote pour
les femmes cette mesure avait été à
l'époque raillée par la gauche qui
voyait comment dirais-je un vieux
réflexe de la droite réactionnaire d'une
politique nataliste et avec cette
amendement on n'a pas eu une seule voix
contre donc bien sûr les maires de
famille on veut les valoriser avec cette
surcote c'est elle qui tiennent aussi
l'équilibre de notre système
démographique il y a les enfants qui
sont orphelins il y a les 10% pour de
majoration pour les enfants pour les
professions libérales il y a le CDI
senior il y a l'arsenal pour la fraude
si on demande aux Français des efforts
pour eux ça n'est pas compréhensible que
certains à l'étranger notamment touchent
des retraites alors qu'ils sont décédées
il y a bien des gens qui les touchent à
leur place donc ce sont ces mesures là
des mesures de pénibilité aussi parce
que l'usure professionnelle on en a
beaucoup discuté et on a fait des
propositions donc ça n'est pas joué
d'avance cette CMP le gouvernement la
majorité présidentielle aurait bientôt
aura bientôt de penser que ce sera
facile les sénateurs croyez moi nous
avons d'abord on fera bloc nous en fera
blocs et on a l'habitude de défendre les
intérêts des Français la première
ministre Elisabeth borne a réagi à ce
vote du Sénat en faveur de cette réforme
de retraite et elle a dit il existe une
majorité au Parlement pour voter cette
réforme vous assumez de participer à
cette majorité bien sûr vous savez
parfaitement vous êtes journaliste à
Public Sénat et vous avez pu observer
depuis toutes ces années que on a déposé
l'amendement qui consistait à faire
cette réforme les 43 annuités 62 à 64
années de quoi aurions-nous
uller si on n'avait pas voté ce qu'on
fait tous les ans tout simplement parce
que c'était le gouvernement d'Emmanuel
Macron qui le proposait non nous on vote
pas en fonction d'Emmanuel Macron on va
pas en fonction d'Elizabeth Board on va
simplement en fonction de de ce qu'on
pense être bon pour les Français
dernière question peut-être sur la forme
de ce débat alors certes le Sénat a voté
au final mais le gouvernement a dû
utiliser un passage en force la
procédure dite du vote bloqué pour
clôturer ses débats du Sénat est-ce que
vous
démocratique non pas du tout pas du tout
écouter c'est un article qui a été
utilisé une centaine de fois sur la 5ème
République et je rappelle aux collègues
de gauche au Sénat sous François
Hollande et il faisait partie de cette
majorité là ils ont utilisé neuf fois
entre 2012 et 2017 cette procédure non
ce sont des procédures qui sont
importantes parce que sinon qu'est-ce
qui serait passé on aurait eu un autre
coup de force une minorité qui
bloquerait qui empêcherait le vote pour
la majorité c'est ça le blocage de la
démocratie je pense que on vit ici chez
nous avec l'abstention une crise de la
démocratie on n'a pas besoin de
surajouter une crise du parlementarisme
est-ce que ce sont tous les républicains
qui sont derrière cette réforme de
retraite et est-ce qu'il y aura une
majorité aussi à l'Assemblée nationale
pour la faire voter c'est la question
que vous connaissez les divisions qui
peut y avoir à l'Assemblée nationale je
pense que le gros des troupes d'Olivier
Marleix votre a cette réforme parce
qu'on a toujours été pour des mesures
notamment de recul de l'âge légal moi
j'appelle vraiment nos collègues députés
être cohérents à être constant voilà
pense que c'est vrai que demander des
efforts ça n'est jamais très très
populaire mais si on veut verser sur le
sur le dans la démagogie d'autres
parties sur ce registre là seront
toujours bien meilleures que nous
peut-être un mot sur la suite de la
mobilisation on a vu une manifestation
avec moins d'affluence aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pensez que ce premier
vote du Parlement d'une des deux
Chambres du Parlement sur la forme des
retraites ça peut un peu affaiblir la
mobilisation je ne sais pas il peut y
avoir un risque en tout cas que les
éléments les plus radicaux je pense un
certain nombre
syndicats des du service public ce qui
d'ailleurs n'auront aucun impact de
cette réforme les fameux régime spéciaux
euh j'espère que il n'en viendront pas à
prendre les Français en otage à par
exemple contingenté encore plus la
production d'électricité à gêner les
Français dans leur déplacement du
quotidien j'espère que justement cette
baisse de pression dans la mobilisation
qu'on a vu aujourd'hui ne se traduira
pas par un durcissement d'une minorité
une dernière question justement autour
des régimes spéciaux à vous aviez un
amendement pour accélérer la suppression
des régimes spéciaux qui est prévu par
cette réforme des retraites est-ce que
au final vous regrettez qu'il ne soit
pas dans le texte qu'il n'est pas été
vraiment débattu bien sûr bien sûr je le
regrette bien sûr d'abord un le
gouvernement n'a pas été courageux
encore une fois avec cette clause
grand-père il a simplement dit à ceux
qui bloquent aujourd'hui la France de
vous inquiétez pas vous n'aurez aucune
conséquence de cette réforme tout
simplement parce qu'il a la trouille de
ces gens là et je pense que c'est pas
c'est pas bien
même pas vis-à-vis de moi mais vis-à-vis
des Français qui devront supporter les
conséquences de la réforme et puis pour
le reste on a dû le retirer puisque le
gouvernement l'avait pas repris donc il
ne pouvait pas être voté j'allais pas
offrir à la gauche voyez un vecteur qui
lui permettait d'accrocher plus de 250
sous amendements et ça nous a écouté des
heures et des heures ma volonté notre
volonté c'était d'aller au vote merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur ce plateau et
justement on va parler de la gauche
sénatoriale dans ce débat sur la réforme
des retraites on va retrouver Mathias
arez en tribune de l'hémicycle du Sénat
elle Matias les sénateurs de gauche ont
tout fait dans ce débat pour débattre
peut-être même un peu rallonger les
débats empêcher un vote au final mais au
final ça a été un échec il y a
absolument Alexandra après avoir
légèrement relâcher la pression en fin
d'après-midi on sentait un petit peu
moins de motivation sur les bancs de la
gauche et bien c'est sénateurs il
voulait réserver une dernière surprise
ici dans l'hémicycle c'est donc Patrick
Kanner qui après
l'expliquer les explications de vote à
prix la parole pour un rappel au
règlement il a donc demandé à appliquer
l'article 51 du règlement l'article 51
alinéa 3 précisément qui permet donc à
30 sénateurs à travers une demande
écrite au président de séance de
constater que la majorité des sénateurs
entendaient le Corum et bien présente
dans l'enceinte du palais pour estimer
qu'un vote est valable donc ça demande
elle a bien été transmise au président
de séance à savoir Gérard Larcher et
pour avant de valider cette demande de
constatation de Corum et bien le
président procède donc à un appel
nominatif à voix haute des 30
signataires seulement voilà et bien il y
a eu un petit raté dans cette
préparation de la gauche puisque et bien
dans les 30 signataires ils avaient
inscrit deux fois le sénateur écologiste
du Bas-Rhin Jacques vernis qu'ils
étaient donc finalement que 29 cette
procédure n'a pas pu être appliquée elle
aurait gagner au moins une heure au
sénateur de gauche avant un éventuel
vote et bien finalement c'était raté et
ça a provoqué lilarité sur les bancs de
la droite Alexandre merci beaucoup
Mathias et oui effectivement dernière
petite manœuvre ratée pour la gauche
pour allonger d'une heure les débats
merci beaucoup Mathias pour votre
intervention et pour votre participation
dans cette soirée sur le vote finale au
Sénat je vous remercie parce que les
huissiers de l'hémicycle vont éteindre
la lumière donc merci beaucoup Mathias
pour continuer cette soirée spéciale en
direct sur Public Sénat alors que le
Sénat je le rappelle à voter en faveur
de cette réforme des retraites et bien
j'accueille sur ce plateau Guillaume
Gontard bonsoir vous êtes président du
groupe écologiste au Sénat votre
réaction à ce vote après 10 jours de
débat ou la gauche quand même c'est
mobilisée pour s'opposer à cette réforme
ah bah c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
la mobilisation elle a été constante
elle a été pleine on s'est battue avec
l'ensemble des groupes de gauche et les
et les écologistes évidemment contre
cette contre cette réforme alors c'est
sûr que c'est toujours
une déception forcément un vote même si
on s'y attend même si on sait que on est
dans un sénat très très à droite avec
une majorité sénatoriale voilà oui il y
a forcément la majorité donc je dirais
que ce à la fois se vote il est logique
mais il y a des choses intéressantes
quand même c'est que par rapport au vote
de l'article de l'article 7 le passage
de 62 à 64 ans on voit bien que déjà la
majorité c'était effrité une
cinquantaine un peu plus de 50
parlementaires du bloc de droite n'avait
pas voté on voit que cette majorité
cette majorité se fissure encore puisque
on est un peu plus de 50 maintenant qui
n'ont qui n'ont pas voté et donc on voit
bien que les débats qui pourtant ont été
musclés je pense qu'on a utilisé tous
les arc fitiches qui pouvaient exister à
la fois par le gouvernement le 47 ans le
44 3 ici les règlements du Sénat pour
éviter qu'on ait la parole pour éviter
qu'on puisse débattre pour éviter qu'on
puisse apporter d'autres perspectives
d'autres solutions pourquoi parce que
justement cette la majorité fragilisées
ne voulait pas que ça se voit ne voulait
pas que ça c'est fait ça s'effrite
davantage mais est-ce que vous
reconnaissez quand même que la gauche et
notoriale a aussi utilisé des artifices
pour rallonger un petit peu les débats
par exemple quand il y a et bien des
amendements similaires ou on change un
mot un chiffre c'est aussi était une
tactique de la gauche alors pour vous
dire c'est que si on reprend le début on
avait on a commencé un texte avec à peu
près 3700 amendements 3700 amendements
c'est loin de quelque chose
d'exceptionnel sur un texte de ce type
là sur ces 3700 amendements un tiers
c'était à droite un peu plus de 1000
amendements on voyait bien qu'on est
parti sur un texte qui était tout à fait
raisonnable avec des amendements et en
tout cas pour le groupe écologiste qui
avait tous du sens qui racontait
justement un autre projet parce que nous
avons d'un autre projet une autre
alternative par rapport à cette réforme
des retraites et puis oui il y a eu
ensuite après l'article 7 le
déclenchement de l'article 38 du Sénat
qui contraint nos prises de parole
l'article 42 qui qui bloque les votes et
puis l'arme fatale avec le 44 3 donc
effectivement ensuite on utilise les
armes qui sont à notre disposition des
sous-allemands etc pour essayer de
remettre les amendements qu'on essaye de
nous supprimer donc oui il y a eu cette
bataille là mais cette bataille là a été
lancée je dirais il y a des agresseurs
et il y a des agressés on a été agressé
effectivement on s'est défendu avec les
moyens qu'on avait avec les moyens d'une
opposition parce que nous on souhaitait
mener ce débat on souhaitait avoir cet
échange je dirais direct frontal parce
que c'est ça la démocratie et là ce rôle
du Parlement il a été quelque peu coupé
et ça c'est particulièrement grave
particulièrement dramatique parce que on
a des gens dans la rue qui attendaient
ça qui souhaitaient avoir ces avoir ces
échanges et ben maintenant il ne reste
plus que plus que la ruée ça ça me
paraît particulièrement dangereux il ne
reste plus que la rue alors aujourd'hui
il y a eu des manifestations en France
avec une moindre affluence par rapport
aux manifestations précédentes est-ce
que vous pensez que premier vote d'une
des deux Chambres du Parlement sur la
réforme des retraites ça peut un peu
décourager la mobilisation les
manifestants non je ne pense pas en fait
la droite les droites la majorité
sanatoriale la majorité présidentielle
la font semblant de croire que ça y est
c'est fini il y a eu un vote c'est
terminé la vraie question c'est après
qu'est-ce qu'on fait maintenant est-ce
que c'est réglé non les Français n'en
veulent pas 90% des actifs
renoncent enfin ne veulent pas de ne
veulent pas de ce texte la question
c'est la suite la suite elle est dans
les mains d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'à
un moment donné il va comprendre qu'on
ne gouverne pas contre son peuple est-ce
qu'à un moment donné il va enfin retirer
retirer ce texte ou alors donner la
parole aux Français il y a aussi cette
possibilité on lui avait proposé ici au
Sénat avec une motion référendaire donc
en tout cas la responsabilité elle est
dans son camp et selon vous la balle est
dans le camp d'Emmanuel Macron merci
beaucoup
d'être venu sur notre plateau pour
réagir à ce vote du Sénat en faveur de
la réforme des retraites merci beaucoup
et dans quelques instants je vais
accueillir Hervé Marseille le président
du groupe centriste au Sénat la majorité
de droite et du centre qui a donc voté
en faveur de cette réforme des retraites
c'est l'information de la soirée au
terme de 10 jours de débats je rappelle
le résultat du vote 195 votes pour cette
réforme des retraites 112 vote contre
votre bonsoir Hervé Marseille
votre réaction en tant que président
d'un des groupes de cette majorité au
Sénat ça y est la Haute Assemblée a
offert un vote à cette réforme des
retraites oui c'est une bonne chose
parce que le la responsabilité et le
rôle d'une assemblée parlementaire quand
on lui amène un texte et bien c'est de
le discuter de l'améliorer et de le
voter on s'étonne presque aujourd'hui
que ça soit ce qu'on demande à une
assemblée parlementaire
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas pu le
faire puisque la minorité a bloqué le
fonctionnement de l'Assemblée
heureusement qu'il y a deux chambres et
c'est une forme de réhabilitation du
bicamérisme et donc je suis très heureux
que le que le Sénat est plus aller
jusqu'au bout de cette discussion ce
vote du Parlement ça va conforter
l'avenir de cette réforme de retraite
face à une mobilisation sociale qui est
quand même très forte avec trois quarts
des Français qui sont contre
c'est possible je sais bien qu'il y a
une contestation je ne la nie pas et
d'ailleurs les
organisations syndicales jouent un rôle
majeur moi je salue leur esprit de
responsabilité et je trouve qu'on
devrait travailler davantage avec elle
mais ça n'est pas dans la rue qu'on fait
la loi nous avons une constitution c'est
au Parlement de voter la loi et de ce
point de vue je trouve très très bien ce
soir que nous ayons pu voter ce texte et
maintenant il appartient à la Commission
Mixte Paritaire mercredi de trouver une
un compromis pour ce texte et de le
faire adopter à l'Assemblée et au Sénat
en quelques mots vous pensez qu'il y
aura un accord entre les sénateurs et
les députés sur cette version commune de
la réforme des retraites j'espère je
suis sûr que la CMP trouvera une
conclusion heureuse après mystère et
boule de gomme je ne sais pas je sais ce
qui se passera au Sénat mais je ne sais
pas ce qui se passera l'Assemblée
nationale il faut que le gouvernement
trouve une majorité sinon ce sera le
49-3
vous craignez vous pensez qu'il peut y
avoir une utilisation du 49-3 à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce qu'il y a
pas de majorité ici nous avons travaillé
parce qu'il y a une majorité sénatoriale
nous avons travaillé à l'intérieur de la
majorité sénatoriale nous avons trouvé
des compromis avec quelques différences
mais nous avons pu apporter la marque
des sénateurs dans ce texte avec des
avancées sur la situation des femmes des
seniors etc et donc maintenant il
appartient à l'Assemblée nationale de
trouver une majorité merci beaucoup
Hervé Marseille d'être venu sur notre
notre plateau sur le plateau de Public
Sénat pour et bien réagir à ce vote du
Sénat en faveur de la réforme des
retraites c'est l'information de la
soirée et c'est la fin de cette émission
spéciale consacrée à ce vote final sur
la réforme de retraite je voudrais
remercier toutes les équipes de Public
Sénat qui ont été mobilisés pendant 10
jours pour vous faire vivre des dizaines
et des dizaines d'heures de débats en
direct également avec notre site
internet public sénat.fr et beaucoup
d'articles de décryptage voilà on espère
qu'on vous a fait comprendre tous les
enjeux de cette réforme des retraites
avec le plus de pédagogie possible merci
de nous avoir suivi pendant toutes ces
journées et toutes ces soirées